the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
Grand chess tour continued to make its
way across Europe for the superbed rapid
and Blitz in Warsaw Poland Arden chess
fans packed the venue to see their
favorite players put on a show when the
beautiful Capital City returning
Champion polish number one Jan kierstaff
Duda looked to be cruising to his second
title leading the event after the rapid
section however despite a slow start the
ultimate Wild Card reigning world Blitz
Champion Magnus Carlson stormed up the
standings blitzing out win after win
leaving a trail of Destruction in his
wake to take the lead but the Polish fee
now wouldn't go down without a fight
battling his way back for a final round
Face-Off between the Titans where a win
for Duda would force a playoff on his
home soil after a furious melee that
went down to the wire the former world
champion was able to secure a draw
cementing his victory and leaving the
stunned crowd in awe with another leg in
the books and a new Champion Crown tour
players set their sights on the host
city of super United rapid and Blitz
Croatia the third stop on the 2023
grantchester tour
foreign
[Music]
welcome chess fans to day one of the
super United rapid and Blitz healthier
in beautiful Zagreb Croatia we started
in the playing Hall as we are waiting
for the players to arrive in just a few
minutes the best chess players on the
planet will battle it all out on the
chessboard it's time to start the action
let's go to the studio in St Louis
the grandchester returns to Croatia it
is rapid and Blitz action with the
greatest players in the world our live
coverage from the San Luis chess club
and the graph starts right now
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome thank you for joining
us I'm International Master nazify kids
and I'm here with my brilliant co-host
the Astro Sarah one Nazi it's so nice to
have you back in studio I missed you me
too so good to be back absolutely hello
everyone and welcome to the Grand chest
tour the Third Edition is about to begin
we had two great events and we'll see if
the third one can produce this much
fireworks as the ones before to remind
everybody where we stand in our grand
chest horror let's just take a look at
the Grand Chester standings let's take a
look we have Wesley saw leading the
granchester so far with the most points
but closely following young Christoph
today and Fabiano caruana with baby only
having played one event he is an
absolutely great position to pick up
some GCT points as we see also alireza
dinglerin and Yan also only playing one
event and now tell us about Zagreb the
roster of Players let's take a look what
a wild card
right world number one Magnus Carlsen
yes indeed a second see the last year's
granchester winner alireza fioruja
American Fabiano caruana World
Championship Challenger Johnny palmnishi
Poland's number one young Christoph Duda
Romanian Grandmaster Richard Rapport and
an absolute Legend five-time world
champion vishwanathanand wherever I see
the Sheena tournament I just have to
smile it's just such an illustrious
career welcome welcome vishy
huge Talent from India gukesh a local
hero Grandmaster Ivan sarich and
Romanian Champion Grandmaster
Constantine lupulesco and tell us about
the format for the rapid and Blitz right
we have a 10 player round robin
tournament in the rapid time control
will be 25 plus 10 in Blitz 5 plus 2.
and in Rapid it's a double scoring
system so the players will get two
points for a win one for a draw and zero
for loss in Blitz they have a
traditional scoring system and the
players are not allowed to offer any
draws
often times in these rapid and Blitz the
players who Finish First in the rapid
often go on to win the tournament so
getting scoring well in the rapid is
very important tell us about the
schedule
we have five days of exciting chess
coming up first three days will be rapid
last two will be Blitz and on Sunday if
necessary we'll have playoffs already
looking forward to that thank you Nancy
and we're very happy to have in studio
Miro Miro welcome to Saint Louis nice to
have you back in the in town uh well hi
yes and Nasi uh thanks very much I'm
happy to be here and as people at home
might have guessed I'll be doing
analysis on the demonstration board but
since there are no games yet let us take
a closer look at the field and
specifically at the wild card
right as you've already pointed out in
the city of Magnus Carlsen world number
one and it's very awkward not to call
him the world champion
uh he'll be the top seed as well as the
wild cardo so well his achievements five
times world champion and Axwell Champion
just doesn't sound right but it was his
decision a year ago during grantchester
Zagreb he was the one to announce that
he is no longer defending the title
anyway big expectations for Magnus well
he's still well number one as we already
said
right and once again I just have to
repeat an absolute Legend Vision on the
oldest the most experienced tiger from
Madras five times world champion and I
am guilty on couple of occasions I was
trying to kind of write Rich write Rishi
off after he's not so good performance
and guess what he always responds by
winning another tournament
foreign
who has proven on many occasions he's
dangerous to literally anyone he has a
win against Magnus Carlsen in a
classical game in his pocket then we
have Constantine lupulesku a very solid
five times Romanian champion and
sometimes to have a good result in those
digit events you just have to be solid
and catch a couple of the bigger guys
off guard and then last but not least go
cash young Talent from India weld used
chess champion for now but you never
know maybe in a few years he will be the
world champion
right and since we are waiting for the
games to start let's hear from Anastasia
and Christian our crew members in
Croatia in Zagreb
thanks uh amiro and welcome chess fans
to beautiful Zagreb Croatia and what an
amazing start we had to this competition
yesterday with the opening ceremony I
have to say from my eyes at least it
looked all like great Vibes Anastasia
first of all good to see you again good
to reunite tell us a bit about your view
of the opening ceremony and what is you
after as well
opening ceremony was really great it was
a beautiful evening and prime minister
visited the ceremony and met with
players as well also we could see former
world champion Gary kasparo himself at
the stage and there were speeches there
was a press conference and after that of
course local chess fans and celebrities
could enjoy the simultaneous exhibition
they actually gave a hard time for
players and three kids managed to win
the games and what was the price for
that the price is really great I mean
all of them will have the right to make
the first symbolic moves on the boards
of their you know stars of the Stars
actually I don't know who should play
after what happened but anyway so the
games are going to start soon and I
would like to remind to all followers
that they can actually go and check our
social media accounts grantchester
please follow us please subscribe to
Instagram Twitter and Facebook accounts
to follow and to see many videos behind
scenes that's absolutely why we are here
for but I have to say I've been uh
having my eyes on two very including
players and mirror you covered a lot of
this exciting wild cards but I'm having
my eyes on two full tour participants
and that is Fabiano caruana as well as
the young French Phenom Ali Reza firuja
and I have to say Fabiano just impressed
in his first grandchester revenge in
Bucharest he in fact won it but want it
comfortably he did not have a single
worst position in that tournament he
picked up 13 points and I have to say he
was quite happy to see Magnus in Poland
take all the full tour of points away 13
points a Magnus won he is the wild card
so he's not going to uh be mattering at
the end the tally the final tally of
granchester's tour points and of course
the second player that I was mentioning
is alireza firuja who I have to say
started slow in Bucharest but towards
the end he was in contention to in fact
win that tournament and give Fabiano a
run for his money definitely two very
exciting nurse guys the battles are
about to begin back to you in St Louis
thank you Anastasia and thank you
Christian as we see alireza they're
getting ready for the start let's
quickly if we can just go through the
pairings uh do the honors Nancy what do
you have for us let's take a look in the
round one cash is playing Magnus Carlson
yeah it's kind of like the two youths
and uh two legends but please continue
with your report facing Fabiano caruana
that's a nice matchup between our tour
participants and lupulasco against
sarich and of course they're going to be
fighting very hard and
for why do they find you they're
fighting for a lot of money there's
total of 175 000 in prizes the first
place winner is going to get forty
thousand dollars second place thirty
thousand third twenty five thousand and
a price found all the way to the 10th of
final place of seven thousand dollars
Grand Chester points if you win the
tournament clear you get 13 points a
bonus of one point if you tie they're
going to be splitting the 12 points is
there you see the tiger Madras the
legend Vichy Duda versus nepo and here
are the youths uh that Anastasia was
talking about apparently they performed
so well wait a minute am I looking at a
tattoo uh yeah that's new yeah I was
about to say what's new
yeah
scary does not like Knight F3 no no no
no no that's Vladimir crime Mix Move
he's forced to play Vladimir's uh
opening move oh my God
let's see if he uh takes it back
he's living it
as we hear uh the Public Announcement it
was something like that in Poland where
Duda and dioc had a proper yeah I could
take the move back no I won't take my
move back Knight F3 D5 G3 I'd expect G6
from no is she going for C5 that's a
surprise
I'm sure he's prepared for this oh yes
oh yes one of the extraordinary things
of uh G6 a few moves later later I think
that throughout all of his career uh
much of
um vichys opening repertoire was
underestimated people really didn't
understand that he was so very well
prepared and that became incredibly
obvious in his world championship match
in Bonn in 2008 against Vladimir kramnik
where he literally won the match with
the black pieces uh playing uh Vichy
let's just jump into the games at the at
the top of the game that I've got on my
board is between gukesh and Magnus and
this comes from we have the Sicilian
yeah Sicilian uh
expecting a special
magnuses with this move order inviting
d2d4 takes and Knight F6 no googash
plays a rosalimo which of course in the
2018 World Championship Match is what uh
yeah now c2c3 it's a completely
different approach from the one that uh
Fabi was doing he was capturing on C6 C2
C3 the idea is to build up a nice center
with D4 Knight F6 Rook E1 all very
standard up to this point 94 and Bishop
E3 the players are quickly zipping
through their preparation Queen B6 and
uh Mira I know that this is all standard
stuff but uh Queen B6 to oh you've got a
different game in front of you you've
got the scotch I think uh I already seen
the database Magnus has played Queen B6
twice before just last year so he's so
all prep yeah good cash will be very
familiar with this
and uh narrow tell us about the scotch
you have in front of you all right yeah
it's not that you know not that
developed just yet it's it's a it's an
opening position in nepo versus Duda but
that's uh that's an interesting line I
have to say especially this h2h4 move
and people's opinion on the scotch game
it always will rise right I mean at some
point Gary kasparo himself was played
playing and with great success this
coach then it was considered harmless
and nepo is one of the guys who are
still pushing and trying to make
something uh right so
we need to or rather should step back a
bit a little bit Yeah D4 is what we call
the scotch game and you can play the
scotch Gambit by going C3 or Bishop C4
not here Knight takes Knight F6 Knight
takes Pawn takes E5
right and once again nothing new for
this place at the very least Queen E2
Queen E7 Knight D5 that's a major
Crossroad in this position and C4
usually is the move then you can play G3
very slowest positional system and this
H4 I remember Alexander morosevicer well
known to some very you know extravagant
a very strong player at some point uh
commenting on this move as why I like
this move it makes zero sense whatsoever
and that was after he won a brilliant
game against Vision with h2h4 so it's a
very venomous move
right and well it developed somewhat
Bishop to E3 so not exchanging the
queens that once again it's it's an
interesting moment because you would
expect after e takes D6 that in some way
it's either black takes only E2 or white
takes only seven nerds freely Bishop B3
and then the tension is uh about like
developing the king side Bishops because
yeah you don't really want to waste the
time moving the queen so it's got a G3
Bishop G2 and for black it's also the
same question do you go G6 Bishop G7 so
that promises us a very interesting
fight and back to you guys but uh Miro
statistically I have to ask in the
position that the players have at the
moment how how do the theoretically
speaking uh score the just the line
score in White's favor blacks uh right
as as I can say it's interesting it's
it's in Black's favor but it's not that
much of a data and most of the games
that as you would expect finishing a
draw and the best move according to
statistics at the very least is D6 to D5
well Bishop E6 was already played right
so here according to statistics the best
was the 6d5 but that's once again uh
with modern computers you probably
shouldn't rely too much on the stats
even from five years ago let alone 10
years ago wow thank you mayor for that
where would you like to take us now I
want to look at the Rapport karwana game
because I think it's fascinating that
Fabi played Richard's opening against
him the French defense it was funny I
just gave a lecture on the 3rd of July
here at the St Louis chess club and I
was doing this lecture on the French
defense where Fabi was white against
Magnus Carl and it was his first Victory
by the defeated Magnus In classical
chess in eight years it was his first
victory over Magnus in eight years on
the white side of the French defense so
I thought you know he'd be cured from
playing the French defenseless black
d2d3 uh I think Bobby plays E6 that
often of course these players can play
any opening but very very rare indeed a
D5 Knight D2 Knight F6 and then a kind
of surprise if you will I think most
most games continue Knight F3 g3 at this
moment E5 by Richie 97 F4 and this is
not your French defense they're your
everyday French defense this one with
the g2 G3 white is looking to play
Bishop G2 and C4 let's see how the game
develops she's known to play very
interesting Sidelines that a lot of them
he comes up with right and I think this
is maybe wonderful oh no question about
it this is really off the Beaten Track
now if I'm in uh Fabby shoes I'm
thinking that I want to attack the White
Center I want to do it either very very
directly and immediately with F7 F6 or
even G5 G5 you know hitting from the
side the problem is once you play a move
like G5 you've got to ask yourself the
question where am I putting my king
you see if you play G5 and for example
right like if I you know if you play G5
and I play for example knight uh F3 and
just for argument's sake you go G4 and I
go back to D2 you're not putting your
King on the king side anymore yeah
probably I think white is putting on the
king side either
okay I'll put my my king in danger uh
but this is a a very different and
unusual uh position I don't know what
the database uh has to say interesting
about this position that Fabio could
also just play B5 and play on the queen
side indeed so he has both B5 and G5
options so it's sort of like you're
playing a king's Indian attack with the
pawn that's normally speaking on F2 on
F4 this is actually a very standard idea
and I've played numerous games uh with
the black side
um I remember pal benko uh from an old
game a long time ago but in that case of
course the pawn is on F to The Rook is
on E1 and I'm going Queen side and he's
going king-site it was a fun game ended
in the draw uh Miro uh jump in and tell
us about this game uh going on this
position
and what does theory suggest after
Bishop G2 yeah you are right yes it's
not very popular variation and not a lot
of theory theory that I'm aware of but
let me let me Comfort you on something
the last move that was played which was
F7 F6 played by farby computer doesn't
really like and it doesn't but guess
what it prefer it prefer your B5 just to
play on the queen side yeah so here
after F6 we still have surprisingly two
games one of them by Judith poga and
yeah for more experienced viewers Robert
even though he represents Romania he's
of Hungarian Origins well I can see some
links here he probably grew up studying
among the others games of Juliet poga so
yeah and capture well even though
computer was recommending Knight G1 to
F3 and perhaps it's too dangerous to
take this Pawn I can imagine like if you
take okay Knight takes first if black
just goes all the way captures the pawn
I guess Castle short or start with Queen
H fight Knight F7 and then Castle short
and black is not happy being a bone-up
because he has quite a lot of problems
to solve uh right so Robert went with e
takes F6 and uh well fabi's Fabi
thinking what to capture with
computer is in favor of Knight F6 but
some people can make an argument for
capturing with the queen possibly hoping
for e65 to materialize
all right
and uh just uh how these two players
match up in their head-to-head Rapids
well could be more even zero zero zero I
think is how we uh score this one right
I think this is results just in the
rapid game yes yes six wins for both of
them and six draws
uh just turning our attention uh to uh
the game of Ali Reza and Vichy for a
second because the players are playing
rather quickly uh an awkward variation
to navigate takes on C4 Queen takes C4
um
the essence of the position funnily
enough is this idea that this Pawn on C5
is really doing a restrictive job if we
ever get in the move d4 we get this
Catalan bishop and nice things can
happen for white on the other hand if
black ever could play Knight to C6 and
Knight on C6 to D4 and simply occupy the
square then from a space point of view
black is doing very well so it's
it's this very uh um tense battle over a
single Square the the Central Square D4
the move Knight E5 obviously opens up uh
the bishop on G2 but in some ways it's
just intimating I wanted to win the two
two Bishops when Knight takes D7 Bishop
E6 Queen A4 check we've been here before
Knight D7 and now this move Knight C4
um essentially what white has done is
said I've drawn your knight away from
the best from the best square and even
though I'm wasting a lot of time I'm
making it awkward for black to have a
harmonious development Queen C7 D3
oldest battle for just the D4 squares
yeah exactly and now white is uh
eyeballing you know gaining a Tempo with
the move Bishop F4 Bishop to D5 uh I
like that of Bishop D5 because the white
Bishop on G2 was a monster absolutely
but here comes the question if they're
Bishop to D4 I guess your queen has to
find
maybe go back to d8 okay
Fair Queen to d8 and
yeah I don't see any things should why
you play E4 and not exchange the Bishops
I would like to do that the problem is I
see it is I've just uh forcing your
Bishop to C6 where he picks up a Tempo
uh that moved Bishop D5 is the most
irritating move there's no question
about it because if I could have just if
you had cooperated nicely and simply
castled then we could see what Ali Reza
would really like is this position where
oops I should actually put the queen on
C C8 because I have to defend yeah and
now we see that these Bishops are
actually doing very nice so these black
pieces are very uncomfortable exactly
holds the entire board right but the
move Bishop to D5
I'm losing my enthusiasm for for Ollie
rais's position after this move Bishop
to D5 it just feels like looks uh like a
good neutralizing move Miro uh you're
looking at magnus's position what's
happening
all right surprise surprise a game of
Magnus Carlson was following the game of
Magnus Carlson uh well up to a point
right you guys had seen Queen to B6
right and Bishop takes Queen takes was
happening in quite a few games one of
them being Duda Carson from a year ago a
bit more than a year ago worn by Magnus
Carson and Knight b2d2 the move that was
played in our game is a rare Choice
according to the database we have it's
only two games were played with this
move one of them by a very decent
Grandmaster Alexander motilev and yeah
okay so Bishop to F5 Knight to B3 B7 B6
and this is the moment where computer
claims that black is already sort of
taking over it's not really better for
black yet but uh yeah you know the
Knight on B3 is very restricted by the
spawn B6 and usually if black girls
basic the the drawback would be that he
weakens the light squares but there is
no light Square Bishop so F to F3
up up sorry I jumped over so B6 Knight
to H4 trying to exchange the above
mentioned light score Bishop Bishop to
E6 F3 well seemingly trapping the Knight
but G5
dropping the anointing response age
takes Bishop G5 F7 F6 and now white
seemingly can win the pawn by capturing
on H4 but the position gets open black
has a pair of Bishops plus the Knight on
B3 imagine the king side opening the
Knight on B3 is somewhat far away from
the actions so it does look like Magnus
has a more promising game
well the position really just blew up in
the my question for you it have is what
was the novelty or is this all still
standard
um Miro I
like Pawn structure
it's these chaotic positions that are so
difficult to judge because you know all
of the guidelines that we have you know
isolated Queen pawns all of these
patterns that we really know insight and
out come to love we don't have any of
those things so this is just uh this is
just a complete mess uh jump in uh Mira
where where did the novelty occur
yeah so the interesting thing nowadays
yes that well the name novelty is no
longer valid I'm afraid because novelty
is something that you do not have games
in the database but then people run
their own servers and pair computers
playing against each other you know
maybe he had everything analyzed anyway
as I've mentioned Knight B to D2 is
already rare and those two games that I
have on a database so Bishop G4 played
and instead Magnus is Bishop F5 which if
you ask me is a Perfectly Natural move
that happens to be a novelty so not a
crushing novelty just a new just a
little of A New Path price for him so
far and the current position yeah and
the current position let me let me
because obviously there was no
transposition you guessed it right it's
an absolutely new position right and
yeah uh just let me take a step back
because at some point computer was
claiming even more of an advantage for
black almost a pawn here Rook C1 Queen
to B7 Bishop takes H4 D2 E4 yeah was
played and then sometimes it happens
with the engines it sort of changes its
mind a little bit it still favors black
but not as much as it as it used to
Queen 2D2 is suggested to play for white
and once again like looking at
computerized lines I sort of lost a
human human Approach at this position I
really can't understand what's going on
everything is going to open up and my
guess is Magnus going to win
yeah those two Bishops should be great
after the position opens up wow uh and
for me this is one of those positions
that is white I want to just go student
body right like I'm looking at the fact
that black is missing a G6 Pawn in front
of his King and in for a penny in for a
pound something like Rook C3 takes on E5
Rook G3 uh you're just going straight
you're just going yeah yeah yeah just uh
throwing everybody over there but on the
other hand this bishop on H4 if the
bishop was on C1 I'd feel
uh better about the pawn sacrifice Queen
D2 something similar the idea of again
of uh coming that missing G6 Pawn draws
my eye Queen on The Rook it's hard to
get our pieces to the king side exactly
exactly also this Knight on B3 uh yeah I
mean just the fact that we're gonna have
to spend Tempe to bringing the night te4
a game unfortunately for a white Wild
Card players are not going to get too
much attention
is the one between Constantine and Evon
I just thought that this was a kind of a
remarkable move by uh Constantine the
move Bishop to D3 I I played this bishop
to D3 idea with the Knight coming to E2
and seeing the Knight on F3 kind of was
a surprise but were you pushing F3 or F4
it depends
a lot of the time F3 but sometimes I
played one game against Yvonne Chuck
where I got an F4 and smashed him lovely
and nicely Bishop to D3 E5 and it's a
king's Indian and instead of having the
bishop on E2 the bishop on D3 makes it
that much more difficult for black to
get in a comfortable F5 Bishop C2 white
is actually waiting for at the move F5
here I think his intention at least is
to take take and then go Knight to G5 so
Yvonne waited Knight A6 Bishop E3 Queen
E7 Knight D2 and the players I think
were up to date with the players after
the move F2 F4 uh definitely off the
beaten path as far as King's Indian
defense positions go but I like
intriguing I know I think Ivan played at
at the right moment and now maybe he can
just play E4 which he just did he's done
it yes uh after this move E4 uh
it's funny I I want this Knight on D2 to
be in two places at once I'd love for it
to be on the E3 square right nice
blockading Square equally I'd love it to
be on the D4 Square where does anywhere
but D2 anywhere but D2 so uh Knight to
B3 to D4 that would have my attention as
would Rook E1 Knight F1 Bishop to D4 and
to get the Knight to E3 uh from Black's
point of view I guess you want to play
King h8 and Rook G8 and and try to use
the half open G file jump in Mirror what
do you think about this position after
the move E4
uh right so after the move E4 computer
turns to like black and well yes I
believe you can confirm and this
computers computer engines and the
King's Indian have a very interesting
Dynamic historically because uh the all
the computers like back in the day 10
years ago perhaps would turn to
overestimate White's position and claim
white is winning whenever he gets the
you know get some space with D5
it has been fixed and I'm wondering if
now computer does the opposite because
it favors black but against the plan
that you've mentioned but simply like
slowly playing Rook to E1 Knight to F1
trying to exchange the bishop well it
fails to demonstrate anything decisive
so I'm wondering if uh you know kind of
dynamic factors are in Black's favor
white has some pieces misplaced but a
long-term plan and especially in a human
game I would still pick white here
thank you mirror yeah it's interesting
to see how the computers rebalance uh
re-configure themselves and as you heard
at the opening of the show Anastasia was
talking about a very very nice opening
ceremony we we just like to show you a
nice clip that we have from the opening
ceremony have a look
welcome to the opening ceremony of super
United rapid and Blitz here in Zagreb
we're expecting the opening ceremony to
start soon with the presence of the
prime minister of Croatia Andre
plenkovic and former world champion Gary
Kasparov let's get to the action
foreign
to be here once again to became a real
tradition to come to Zagreb to celebrate
cheers over here with the greatest
players in the world I I want to just to
assure you that our foundation will
continue to bring the chess to you we
are chess lovers and we'll try to bring
Grand Masters here to have a nice
example for the kids to try to educate
them to give to them the chance to
become better people there's having a
quick work with them with my friend and
colleague Luciana I realize that it's
the first big tournament where one of
the participants in this case book HD
was born after retired from chess
that definitely fills me very old next
year we'll celebrate Justin's Library
again thank you
it was an amazing opening ceremony which
was broadcasted live on the national
television of Croatia many chess fans
came here and were happy to see all top
chess players and now it's time to get
back to the games
foreign
that did look like a fun opening
ceremony in the quip thereby Gary that
gukesh was born after his retirement wow
um very quickly uh as time flies and
you're having fun and there you see uh
gukash playing against uh Magnus and
let's just jump uh quickly into that
game because guess what after Bishop
takes H4 takes on e4 he did play the
move Rook C3 and again it was a student
body to the right side of the board as
Black's King is missing the G6 Pawn now
I was expecting Magnus to actually
capture the pawn and challenge white to
prove his attack Magnus had notes he was
not interested and after the move uh F5
well very quickly Bishop G5 almost Mira
I I almost want to say
could this be prep I mean no I I can't
imagine that that that gukesh has
prepared this position because he played
Bishop G I mean before the move Bishop
G5 was played there's some very nice
ideas here for White Queen H5 Rook G3 uh
amongst them but Bishop G5 was played so
quickly I think it's proud
what do you think
Mira yeah you're waiting for you to
finish yes sir sorry can't possibly be a
prep unless it's a very bad prep or a
gambling because computer clearly favors
black really and you were absolutely
right F5 well sorry Magnus but happens
to be not the best move indeed well you
know how it is with computers nowadays
you expect your attack to be sufficient
or at least threatening but guess what
the Monster does Rook a to d8 claiming
there is no attack whatsoever and only
when you play Queen H5 it does take care
of defending the bishopon G7 by playing
Bishop F5 and then to G6 all going Rook
F7 and it's more than a pawn in Black's
favor so in our game after F5
still black who you should prefer but
not by huge margin Queen C1 was a very
very cool opportunity that he apparently
missed because not only you are
threatening Rook to C7 but also Queen
g5s a multi-purpose move and it would
almost equalize the chances so instead
he went with Bishop G5 still playable
and am I right Magnus is to move yeah
according to computer Magnus has to play
F5 F4 which is I wouldn't say very
natural yes it's a very bold move to
play once it's on the board and that's
very often with computer suggestions
once it's on the board you immediately
realize ah okay so he plays F4 to cover
the G3 Square not the loud Bishop F4 and
so on and so forth but to consider a 504
move you have a beautiful Pawn chain so
at least some stability and all of a
sudden you have to play a force it's not
an easy move to play Let's see what
Magnus does not an easy move at all and
I see that move F4 that strikes me as
yeah I think that's a move I would make
in Rapid in Rapid City uh I like uh I
was plated and it just played it I I
like that move Queen C1 the more I saw
that move the more I liked it as well
sort of like you're playing for these
dark squares and ideas of Bishop
um to G5 I find Bishop G5 to H6 to be
very attractive especially once you see
rookie set Rook C7 as well so Queen C1
uh definitely uh was a nice one Bishop
to G5 F4 and again we're back to this
chaos but I was really surprised Mira
when you said the engines gave a very
clear advantage to Magnus is that still
the case with these last two moves
yeah well as I said F5 perhaps wasn't
the best and well once again sometimes
human understanding proves to be right
you have a pair of Bishops you really
want to open the position up right so F5
and then as we both mentioned Queen C1
would have been almost an equal game
Bishop G5 and then if Magnus would not
play F4 their position would be equal
according to computer and then when you
are shifting from something that was
better for you to equal it usually goes
downhill from here anyway so F4 a cool
move Queen to C2 and queen C2 is a
terrible terrible mistake I have to say
at least according to computer because
now by playing H6 Bishop H4 E4 E3 well
computer claims it's a decisive
advantage and by decisive it's almost
three points two and a half pounds that
you can say Well it goes down a little
bit but I believe yeah that's that's a
really really
but the mistake that he made I I hate to
argue against the computer but I think
the move Queen C2 had a dual purpose
idea the first of course is gift me the
pawn on e4 but the second was to play
Rook to C7 so after your move H6 which
looks really fine I I'm I'm pouncing
with the move Rook C7 pouncing me you
like that
it's yeah so this is computed let's try
not obviously and this would have worked
yes if not for Rook a to C8 and that's
his this is yeah for people at home this
is the problem we Grand masters of the
past so to speak have against the
computers because the understanding is
there and your plans are good they just
don't know don't work tactically
tactically yeah and after Rook ac8 it
slides out yeah you I don't know what
you have to do you're basically and
couple of Pawns down according to
machine take take Rook F7 yes sir it's
minus seven only yeah I'm not giving up
right but what's interesting once again
yeah so you have the correct idea of in
this position of double attacking or
playing multi-purpose it just had to be
once again Queen to C1 and this will
work because the queen is protected on
C1 so whenever we have a trick with Rook
to C7 black won't have Rook a to C8 so
that's a tiny but very important
difference and of course you can play H6
right now because your F4 Pawn is
hanging so had good cash played the move
Queen C1 uh it's still it's still better
for Magnus it's just not as bad yes
still E4 E3 and then if you try Rook C7
Queen he drops the pawn but he goes
either Queen E4 Queen D5 computers
indecisive between the two I'd suggest
Queen E4 you know closer to the king
Bishop to D5 next it's a very dangerous
initiative absolutely sure it looks that
way as well and the current position
though like you said it's almost three
point points in favor of Magnus and he
did play H6 yeah he did play H6 and
and yeah and gookash is still thinking
after H6 that stopped him yes yeah and
basically
it explains a lot right so he was
relying on Rook C7 right exactly and uh
the queen C2 kind of missed Rook C8 oops
Yeah now bookesh is in real trouble we
should take a look at uh nipom nishidura
game because I think that game is also
kind of was blowing up it is up a pawn
however there's some conversation for it
well this was the scotch and when we
left it uh Mira was explaining that you
almost expect one player to either be
playing Queen takes E7 check and or
queen E2 the Queens didn't come off the
board and then the question is how are
we going to develop our Bishops on f8
and F1 well apparently very easily both
sides Castle
um but I want to also
take a notice uh at their time Jan as
always in his style playing really fast
he has 20 minutes on the clock wow again
stood as seven minutes that's a big
difference
and in their heads to head matchups
let's see how they score against one
another slightly in the floor in yeah
six wins four losses and five draws
okay but uh for for Yan I mean uh
considering duda's performance in Poland
this is pretty darn good six wins
and by the way there's a vacuum uh that
just occurred in this game as uh yeah or
everything just kind of got hosed off
the board but
dudas a pawn pawn and he has a passport
on the side which is very nice but his
king is not the safest so he has to keep
the Rook on G8 which is unpleasant to
have its defending the G7 so passively
exactly
um is this enough Advantage for black to
win
probably not but on the other hand it's
a great success for Duda that you know
he came out of all of these opening
complications with the pawn in hand so
good for him a game kind of got away
from us a little bit the game between
Richie Rapport and Fabi when we left it
we did see that French defense with F7
F6
captures the pawn and this is where the
computer
really does I think
distinguish itself
the willingness of the computer just to
sacrifice upon and say look you know
I've got these you know tremendous
Dynamic attacking chances for the pawn
in development yeah I'm ahead yeah and
uh for us humans we would sit there and
go well the material like uh
he ended up capturing on F6 and I think
that gave Fabi the free play that he
needed to just well I mean
in the current position I really like
fabi's Knights on e4 and F5 exactly they
make a great a great impression
and Miro another game that got away from
us the Vichy game uh what's happening
there
uh well there's a lot has happened there
and well stepping all the way back I
claim that alireza ferrugia has unlocked
the achievement of giving two similar
checks Queen A4 check by move 10 and
yeah on a bit of a more serious note
it's uh quite a rare line already then
Queen A4 check
uh was played and one of the games I can
see is Anish giri against Michigan was
following his own game
uh right up to the point and you guys
explained in detail what was happening
here after Bishop E6 yeah that's the new
tag and we are left with three games
only one of them of the players I don't
really know then we have giri against
Anand and we have and that that's
important we have one game from
so-called correspondence chess and these
are the guys who spent days and
sometimes weak analyzing their next move
so these games are usually of a very
good quality Knight b2d7 still following
giri Anand Knight to C4 and that's a
giri apparently didn't play Knight C4
yeah and then we've gotten to this
moment when the Bishops were exchanged
and you pointed out
how well how good it is for black so
black is safe and computer tends to
agree that from now on it's equal and
starts to be in Black's favor
um not really sure where was the moment
where alireza kind of misplayed it Queen
B3 looks dubious according to computer
even though it's attempting move Queen
has nothing to do on A4 anyway if we
move a bit further so let's move 16 and
in five more moves we are having this
position we're still roughly equal B5
exchange on B5 exchange on B5 Knight to
D2 back Knight here Queen C2 and queen
C2 happens to be not a good move
uh right so computer is saying yeah
basically there is something that is
threatening which we don't know yet but
he had to play Knight C to E4 well
blocking the diagonal also applying some
pressure on C5 and queen C2 happens to
be just a little bit too slow so Knight
G4 and now you no longer have a chance
to play Knight E4 black will capture the
bishop and the best according to machine
once again was move Knight to F1 but
this is not the move you play happily
right so black will exchange your dark
Square bishop and have no problem
whatsoever possibly better chances
instead ferrugia went with Bishop F4 and
E5 was the best that was it wasn't
played Bishop to D4 and once again the
problem with Bishop to D4 is once again
it allows black it allows white to play
Knight to E4 I don't think it's played
yet so farooja is thinking so it goes
back and forth a little bit at some
point looked very promising for Anand
but this fight is still ahead of us
thank you uh Miro I just wanted to turn
to the game of Constantine and Ivan
sarich for just a moment because well
you know uh in this moment why does
eyeballing this Pawn on A4 and he's
looking to play Knight to E2 to D4 so
Knight C5 and do you take the pawn
Constantine thought about it and said
give me the pawn but look what he gave
up after Knight takes A4 Bishop to D4
check that is just a monster Bishop uh
in the middle of the board and after
King H1 well you don't have to be a
puzzle Rush Champion to see what's
coming up next uh Rook H6 Rook takes H2
and after the move Knight B3 we've
caught up with the players and I I'm
thinking after Rook age six you're
almost forced to take before response I
know and uh well let's just say you you
black has great compensation
King's Indian gun really well for black
exactly uh something has gone uh
missed on this one uh let's jump to the
game of gookash and Magnus for a second
because after this move H7 H6 Bishop
dropped back to
um H4 Pawn on e4 is still hanging Rook
on C7 looms over the position and then
we saw the move E3 Queen G6 and
[Music]
I don't know it looks like a good move
to me I guess go cash wants to play
Queen C6 and maybe exchange the Quince
that's what I thought as well exactly
Queen to C6 although you know I was
hovering over on the king side there for
a moment uh I think Queen C6 is more or
less
required I can't hover more with
questions maybe instead of Bishop F5
Blackshear flavor Bishop D5 and not
allow that exchange okay I really like
the bishop and queen set up on the
diagonal
yeah it's it's especially uh concerning
that I I've got no Rook G3 ideas I my
Knight has really stuck uh unfortunately
and Magnus made a move he played Queen
D7
instead of Bishop D5 to D7
okay that looks great too it does uh I
mean it's like the the queen is all
dressed up it looks really pretty on G6
but it's all alone it's all alone I I I
have no uh Supporting Cast it's very
hard to come up with good moves for
white here exactly it's not that I'm
afraid
afraid of takes and takes it's just that
I don't see how I'm going to coordinate
White's pieces I suspect this is one of
those positions that's just incredibly
favorable for black uh
Miro I just don't see how White's
coordinating
over to you so you would think yes that
this one is close to be winning for
black wouldn't you yes and guess what
you're absolutely right
it's so helpful to have such an
insightful commentators because you one
day identified I think the key to this
position better than gupcash because as
far as I understand he was really hoping
for Queen G6 and then Bishop to F5 Queen
C6 uh while exchanging the Queens black
would still be better in this case but
it turns out yeah we had an image of
black king being weak right and white
forces joining the attack but it's in
the past and now as you've absolutely
correctly pointed out white has tough
time coordinating so each of your moves
Bishop to D5 or queen to D7 would lead
to Great Advantage for black yeah so
after Queen D7 the move that was played
in the game uh well Rook e to c one
fault and then once again a chess player
in me he wants to play positional game
with Rook a to C8 or something but yeah
computer is just merciless he says well
we don't care we exchange a beautiful
Bishop because we want the default pawn
and claims that black is well the
evaluation is plus four which means like
four pawns up which means winning yeah
four pounds that's just huge
because I think after taking on D4 E5
Falls as well yeah it takes Queen takes
to D4 well you have to go Rook C7 there
is no way back and then yeah then black
just plays Rook a to E8
that's interesting I thought blackhead
E2 and queen D1 right away
instead of rookie eight does that work
uh well he blocks I believe he blocks
with uh Bishop yeah we can try this one
E2 check King I'm sorry so E2 check
discovered check and yes you're right
Queen D1 is a threat but he goes away
and queen D1 for Now does not really win
because white can block with the bishop
but yeah even after that Queen D1 is
unnecessary but even after that black
still has the advantage
nice uh Queen takes D4 uh the Deep Pawn
connected to the E Pawn and uh away it
goes I think we have another game
getting close to -4 it's Duda against
the publishing wow uh at first when they
the players entered this uh major piece
ending extra Pawn for Duda I thought
yeah okay you know you you struggle and
you you try your best to win I didn't
think it was that bad but uh as
we continue forward it's very clear that
well the extra Pawn is Meaningful and
even worse White's King is the one who's
getting hunted down here a little bit as
well King H7 and queen D6 that's one
problem for Duda it's time he has less
than three minutes left and it's very
easy to miss Perpetual check or some
kind of tactic in a position like this
right
uh here uh
the problem is it's only one check it's
not like the so can white at some point
just push G5 try to okay E3 is on
everything and so until we put the King
on F2 back to F2 makes sense so that
after for example A3 now you want to
play your G5 ideas yeah
um I'm desperate so I have to try
something exactly exactly G5 now here I
can take away do you want to play check
first and then play G5 because here I
can take away the check
show that after for example King G3 now
you don't get you know well I wanted to
keep the queen on 86 just in case maybe
I'll take the pawn on A3 if you give me
some checks okay so well okay so we're I
think we've just played the move Queen
D3 do you want to play G5 or King F2
first right you want to play King F2 A3
and then G5 exactly okay so King F2 A3
no check but G5 right away and if I give
you check you go back I've got a tempo
against your Rook
although
Queen juice no G6 Queen to six take four
that's still a lost hurricane game
because you're up too many pawns I feel
that's the case right it has to bear in
by the way Queen E6 no G5 six was played
uh and no King F2 either just cool he's
defending the pawn on E3
yep but after A3
what do we do now
that is the key question what are we
doing about the runaway criminal uh A3
A2 that pawn is Unstoppable so in my
must have some ideas on the king side
and well they're playing quickly so let
me update my he played uh Rook F7 Rook
F7
so is it a bluff or does he actually
hats oh I think I think he has Perpetual
check ideas if you push A2 yes which I
want I'm gonna take Rook G7
what why it takes Rook takes you seven
well it takes G7 Queen F5 check and
you've got checks on the diagonal
wow
that's yeah I think so too I think that
as uh I mean and I I I'm not Waltzing
away right right so King F6 Queen D6 not
a five because then you go to E7
right and here I can't go to G5 I walk
in the maid so 27 back and that's like a
Perpetual so rookie that's that's a
nasty Perpetual Rook F7
um
and if I play King h8 can you still play
Rook takes G7 that's crazy oh wow wow
yeah I can't anymore because it can take
Rook G7 Queen E8 and King H7
I was going to check you on the diet no
then you go to G8 so he's played Queen
bhek recognizing Duda recognizes that
there are pets Perpetual checks is a
great in between move now we protect the
last rank so you can just push the pawn
now because 57's no longer a threat King
H3 so no no Rook G7 anymore
and there you have it A2 on the board
today's down to us minute but I
think well a winning position
maybe he may be short of time but it
feels like a winning position uh here
and Miro uh let's turn it over to you
and Magnus and googesh how are they
doing
uh while Magnus is a machine right so he
went he took the machine part and that's
that's what we have he just captured on
B3 and captured on D4 and that's what
we've that's what we've discussed
already that's absolutely winning for
black and I use this moment to cheer for
you guys you've absolutely spot on
analysis on nepo's game because you've
identified there was a Perpetual with
Rook to G7 and yeah just let me let me
bring it over here yeah Rook G7 your
your line if black doesn't play Queen
bhx A2 and it's yeah it's a beautiful
Rook sacrifice with a Perpetual check
and you're absolutely right that Queen
V8 is a very strong in between move
after which black is completely winning
wow
uh at first when they entered this major
piece ending I didn't think it was that
cut and dry that simple I want to say
for Duda a very impressive technique uh
all the games by the way have kind of
exploded even the game of Fabi and
Richie is also uh double-edged as well
nothing by the way I just want to
mention that gupcash and Magnus were
just teammates last week in Dubai
exactly playing for the global chess
event and Magnus even made the comment
that his team kept winning because go
cash kept winning every game indeed uh
All-Star for uh magnus's team and it was
quite a shot that magnus's team did not
get to the finals Rook C7 on the board
this is where you were mentioning E2
check and queen to D1 uh Magnus just
playing Rook to E8 and saying okay I'm
not going to allow any counter play
based on takes E7 the difference
obviously is that you need your Bishop
to defend the mate so Rook takes E7 Rook
takes E7 Bishop takes E7 it's nice to
have E2 as an option on every move
exactly the Discover check just
looks so very powerful Rook E8 prepping
and again this queen on G6 looks really
beautiful but without backup do you
think okay should bring the queen back
maybe Queen G4 and try to put it on E2
play defense yeah
well let's uh jump over to a Zagreb with
Christian who has a very special guest
in studio Christian over to you
yes indeed we do have a very special
guest The Mastermind behind the grand
Chester and the 13th world champion Mr
Gary Casper of Gary first of all welcome
back to the show I've seen you last time
in Poland now we're in Croatia it seems
like everywhere the granchester goes
there's so much love absolutely but I
think it's I'm so happy now we have
Traditions Bucharest Warsaw Zagreb and
of course you know we everything will
end up in St Louis yes yeah uh but yeah
it's it's a traditional year and I think
it was spectacular opening cerebral
yesterday absolutely I mean look 45
minutes live front prime time so it's
this on national TV and I was a prime
minister and members of the government
you know attending and I think it was
phenomenal yeah and I mean that's it
shows that you know chess could also you
know offer value for a sponsor yeah so
it's not just you know charity it's it's
a big deal and uh I think the Superman
is happy and uh
you know I think chess players are very
happy because the standards are very
high I mean you just see you know you
could see their chess as the game that
receives respect it deserves absolutely
and every single Ballroom that we go to
it gets filled in Romania it was filled
in Poland I mean oh my God what was uh
what was many more people following yes
now it's like it or not but it's the
most prestigious tournament in
networking in in the world and now with
Magnus you know dropping out of official
cycle and uh participating in in
granchester so that definitely adds you
know Prestige to our event speaking of
one participant in the grandchester is
Duda who's been having a pretty decent
year he did well in Bucharest he did
very well on home turf in Poland and
right now what a great start against
Nepal with the black pieces of Victory
yes yes it's just it's
missed the moment because the position
was not great but uh but nothing just
the
and this is from my perspective I mean
there's nothing was indicating that it
was such a disaster for for for Nepal so
quickly in fact it seemed like he had a
better preparation he got the scotch on
yes I know on the board prepared but I
just you know it's the he played very he
was was exuberant confidence but I
wasn't sure why you're so confident I
mean it's just because the way I
understand chess it's it's it's it's you
know he didn't tell me that his position
was so great so we'll see because black
had a solid position in the center C5
Pawn is
questionable Pawn H5
yeah and this was the mistake you know
which was as my late coach and then the
kids and said you know in this position
so H5 the best move forward H4 H2O
yeah and this seems to be uh sort of
what led to his demise this Pawn on H5
became a weakness later on but we still
have some games going on Magnus seems to
be doing quite well he didn't do well in
the beginning in Poland after that we
were discussing at some point and we
weren't really still thinking
he did he did he did come back it's a
Pity that he just he plays here only you
know
as a wild card on the full participant
of the tour so he'll be still you know
Mississippi Lewis but again it's just
his performance in Warsaw and was was
outstanding okay the the bullets bullet
section of that yeah yeah uh and uh
let's see what happens happens here but
again is is undoubtedly easily a
favorite you've been uh gauging their
Vibes at the opening ceremony you talked
with Magnus quite extensively you were
talking with nepo as well who did you
feel was in the best shape or in the
best mood
is relaxed now so that's why I guess was
that way you never know you know just
you know is but I think it's it's hard
in apple and he understands you know
he's you know
you know he's a sensitive man and
obviously you know this horrible War and
the fact is that he's you know even
technically he's just he's I know how
you feel being Russian especially you
know if you stay there so and I think it
has pressure it puts pressure on you
yeah he he knows that he
he somehow also shares his Collective
responsibility for this heinous crimes
committed in your brain so that's why I
think it's difficult for him to play
definitely feels like there's some
psychological pressure on on Apple right
now we're hoping that he's going to show
his best self in this tournament but
let's discuss this position I mean is
there anything to discuss exactly at
this point
I'm you know I'm puzzled by the opening
choice because as we discussed it
briefly just uh let's say uh the idea
this this is the black should play D5
instead of exchanging on D4 that's
that's that's late 80s early 90s because
when I started playing chess services in
the 70s that's that was kind of what it
is CD4 CD for D5 e594 and then Knight C3
so I remember I just I played it in in
in
tournaments as a kid typically we're for
black pieces yeah so that was when and
then you know just was the discovery
that we can play D5 and I think this was
a kind of consultation game I played
after match was Nigel 93 on stage so and
I played with someone against Nigel and
someone and we played D5 and I think
they took on that was quite a surprise
took on D5 and play with some kind of C4
but it's not not good so the Rival 4594
and and I remember I played it this was
against
shirovies I think in
yourself in
2002 maybe 2002 probably is yeah and I I
took on C6
and uh after day five yeah uh actually
it might be my maybe maybe even almost
when my I mean I saw in the house maybe
it was BIG my boss
I don't just want one of them I'm not
sure which one yeah yes this is the I
took on C6 and no no no no if I if 594
yes and then to take on C6 and Knight
bd2 that's the yeah that's the
and then this is black would take one I
think should have played Bishop for five
year endings I think so but I'm not here
I'm not sure already but but Bishop is
three is just you know it's it's I mean
it's very ambitious you want to trap the
night but it just it doesn't it doesn't
look like you know you can do with cd40
I might just play very quickly yes
knight bd2 uh Bishop F5 and I look
Knight B3 I don't know it's this could
try playing at F1 here because the idea
is actually to trap the Knight on D4
yeah so another foreign
could eventually
show up on E3 or somewhere but after
maybe maybe F6 here but again no six is
just still this this stuff they've seen
this is not what's the next move yeah
actually I'm not sure what's the White's
next move black maybe play G5 I don't
know just what's the white snakes still
very complex and I'm sure Magnus was a
horrible
yeah yeah he was playing very very
confidently he started this for the
world championship yes yes and he played
B6 which is provoking Knight H4
provoking in Knight H4 cutting this
Knight and a free G5 yeah but it's the
that's
very nice game so far and I think we we
still have a few moves we're just about
to potentially see resignation yeah a
few moves very few years
this might be a resignation time Bishop
G3 to defendant
is
yes and let's see Gucci has 30 seconds
let's see the resignation yeah
slow start for gokish but we kind of
seen him do that often you know he's
just it's his first his first event
in register in branches too yeah first
time he gets the Wild Card yeah exactly
definitely a big moment for him exactly
that's this
do you do you think there's some
pressure he's feeling some pressure
and the first first the first game you
play with animals
he definitely has this cool car
collected look on his face but inside of
him there must be a fire burning
isn't queen of fun just mate
F6 and Rook G6 yeah yeah this one Rook
F3
resignation
still fighting he's a fighter
there's not much fight left foot there
we go we have a handshake in this one
great start for for Magnus
um
one of the it's so strange to call him a
wildcard yeah he's so good he he stole
13 ranches through points in in Poland
he's going to try to do safety still
again yes it's uh it's difficult to call
him a wild card
let's see what do we have another one of
uh
this is not doing badly yes
oh yes the old man yeah
yeah he has some chances but just to
stay on this one because Richie only has
a few seconds left
it was
so he's back to move 97 is coming
um that is coming anyway how do you
defend against nine percent comes anyway
no that's what you do yes yeah it's
probably a draw maybe Rook E6
yeah
so what doesn't change anything
you can go crazy sorry sorry
seven
first person
yeah well protect everything is
opposite called The Rook and F1
7 20 seconds for Fabiano also this one
is turning into
two oh let's slap quizzes into seven
okay
I remember in Poland
we had one of these games exactly
yeah
and now we're going to see my
great predictions
yeah actually you'll see which which way
it goes to the queen because this is the
yeah after 25 25 Knight letter another
four yeah that's easy that's really
immediately will not afford the 93.xf2
just you know two just to avoid yes
neither one of these three just you know
another four maybe we should be six
years
there's still something
it's a dead draw I don't see this is I
would be very surprised because I see
okay technically yeah you can definitely
try to play an E3
8 now let me move
okay
maybe 93 was a bit
you go 95 back now
and then he plays G5
oh
okay yeah it's it's okay but you don't
do
you can take knight from D5 to F1 I mean
it doesn't come out that's the that's
you had a score on the F4 Square I mean
very good Square for the Knight yeah
yeah and we have another result from the
colasco versus sarich has been in
general that's that's how you lose
G5 yeah yeah maybe it's not still
another form it's still dropping
yes is it yes he sees it
yeah Bobby had some chances no what
no what you bought and this one I
believe it's a draw as well yes alireza
this is a true battle of generations
it is
that one was a drum and this is the
final game
pending but
do you think Richie at some point starts
playing for a win
I mean serious serious this is a brave a
win what what can you do it's not on the
phone yeah yeah it's probably not going
to happen
look in theory you should be careful
because you know this you have to move
the King on it just you know
H3 because this is in theory Bishop goes
Queen goes in F2 now giovann but then
King goes on h2h3 so this yeah yeah
players definitely realize that
perhaps soon
foreign
still okay inviting captioning
why you want
this is nothing
like Queen F2 which is creates no
threats okay nowhere no threats yeah
so let's see foreign
you want
maybe I can just actually then then you
start playing for a week look at full
yeah Rooker four now uh this is yeah I
think why not yeah no but now is if I
get an iPhone no the
and then night moves from H2 to
low maybe maybe you're right so this is
this I'm not sure you want to put the
queen on G1 yeah
make sure night doesn't go away because
if Knights
show up sometimes on F5 somewhere you
may have a little challenge yes it's not
enough
we have we've seen this type of
imbalances go wrong for the queen king
G5 now yeah
some Queen H7 ideas yeah but that still
is the
Check Yes but
but King G5 now
looking forward to to to block and then
prepare
yeah it's difficult to take the Knight
out
yeah that's the question will he get
overly ambitious by the way he made that
move with two seconds
he's protected the pool
definitely feels like a good movie
should start just to forget but don't
get too ambitious they just make a
Perpetual make a Perpetual that's you
know I think Richard is starting to play
foreign
six
analysis
look after someone not the greatest idea
how they
you can
after just now Mike is doing another
five do they tell you that goes on F5
Knight E3 and then that goes on F5 going
for it yeah this is the question is can
you do Perpetual of the queen E2
Knight effect Queen H5 hopefully not the
hh4 so
it's much more difficult than it should
have been should have ever been
the five now Queen H5 Knight H4
still everything conducted is he's
protected and Knight goes and that's why
Knight goes on F5
foreign
that's a good question
before
he has not to lose the peace
yeah
E5
and then he should decide maybe ibrah
King is riches the king is
immediately yeah this is the
only five
you take on D6 because this then it's a
draw but if you can actually
just
I would keep the Knight just I also did
because because no because we'll get
four guys were made
it's made
King G4 Rook H2 is also no it's made yes
before goes a trial is made yeah that's
that's why I'm just you know I think
it's a student and you don't have chats
yeah this is a real threat right now I
think Rock H2 is over if you don't we
don't pay attention what is this
what is happening wow
wow kimchi foreign
wow
seven rookies two Rook H sixes still
made yes wow this is over
wow
foreign
is a very solid position as usual a
pleasure to have you here commentate the
games with us tell us a bit about the
grand chess tour okay let's uh The Show
Goes On yeah we'll see you in the next
couple of days of course I'm around
and right now we're going to go on a
short commercial break and we'll be back
shortly with round two
[Music]
we should welcome back to soccer if you
were here in 2021 what kind of memories
do you have from that event
uh 2021 the Zagreb tournament
first of all it was a very long event
because I had to come three weeks early
due to the pandemic and so I I remember
that tournament is just being in these
surroundings forever and in a pleasant
way I mean you're in a nice city right
in the center for a month and um
and I had lots of local friends here
coming and trying to give me company and
so on so it felt not only like a very
big tournament but also very social one
and um
uh it was very important because it was
a very good result for me and it gave me
a lot of confidence that year
um
yes and I hadn't played much and so I
when I came here and I finished second
that year uh you know that was a very
positive thing to take away and uh Gary
was also playing in that event so a big
event this year again it will be very
very tough that's the thing if you have
just all the top players in the
grandchester so tough event and but
again I've learned a meeting up all my
friends and all that and trying to get
into a positive spirit for the event
yeah absolutely the last time we saw in
Manchester was actually in Poland last
year and you were leading I remembered
the whole event and only at the end slow
down a little bit and still came third
like what are your you know goals in
this one are you going to push also to
try to get into the first places
my attitude always is you have to play
Move the pieces and the position has to
take care of itself you don't really aim
for this or that but of course I'll try
to do my best and play good moves
um
yeah like I said your your score if as
long as it keeps moving along uh
hopefully it's uh it keeps you in the
front
now that you play rapid and Blitz I mean
do you have some special kind of tricks
and methods methods how to stay focused
I mean during those games
generally when we have uh this because
we start with the rapid you have to
first get in with three games every day
uh with the draw after the drawing of
lots today we will know the who we play
um
for me it's a step up because in the in
Dubai I was playing one game a day yes
and so here suddenly we go to three and
uh but it's a format I'm used to I
played in Warsaw I played it in sagreb a
couple of years back when I was a full
tour participant I was playing
um two or three a year so
um
I'm used to this format generally you
try to get into the tournament fully uh
pick concentration and all that by the
end of the rapid
and then the blitz just goes past you
you have no idea what happens and you
just you just see where you ended up
with it
I mean also um I mean speaking about
many events you mentioned the other
events of granchester what is was the
most memorable event for you
um for all during all these years
I like many of them
I generally you can imagine I remember
the good results better than the bad
ones
and so there are some events that leave
us car on you but mostly the
grandchester events have just superbly
organized and I really enjoy playing in
them and like I said from two years ago
I have very good memories of Zagreb and
hopefully I can carry these wipes
forward to this year as well for sure I
mean also this event is special because
uh googesh is playing here and I had the
interview with him before and he said
that he is really looking forward also
to play against you and it's the first
tournament you're in the same one so
what do you think about him and his
participation he's a new for
grantchester
yes I'm very very proud of what he's
doing he's
I mean just a couple of years back he
was starting his race and this year he's
been very consistent he had a good
result in
WR good recovery in bike
um very good performance in Norway so
you know steadily making his way up and
now it's funny to talk about him some
sort of young Talent he's just number 15
in the world exactly so you know there
he is
um
and you know the nice thing is for the
last couple of years he has been one of
um
the students in my chess Academy
and uh it'll be funny to play him that's
true that's exactly what I'm looking for
and probably there will be I'm not quite
sure how to place it I just figure I'll
go there and look at the pieces and uh
you know not try to make a special game
out of it but just play good chess yeah
do you remember yourself at the age of
uh and like what were your thoughts at
that time
uh uh I remember I think I remember it
incredibly well uh generally my memory
now was
that everything was fun and everything
was nice and new and life seemed
exciting but uh
probably if I go back it was not quite
that straightforward uh typically your
Nostalgia takes over but I remember you
know these first chances at the big
tournaments and all how exciting they
were and yeah and the last question just
what do you think was the impact of
Grant's store itself for the history of
Chesterfield sport
in general these are clearly the premier
tournaments
uh in the world and you know they are
marquee events that everybody look
forward to and I think the the beauty of
the grandchester is because the points
accumulate at the end there's also this
curiosity not only who wins tournaments
but who is leading in the overall race
and who will win the tour at the end so
that's like an extra bonus like
um this year-end uh titles that they
have in many sports uh the grandchester
has great classical events great rapid
and Blitz events but also a tour winner
and that's a nice thing yeah exactly
thank you very much for your time and to
answering my questions and all the best
of luck for you in soccer thank you
[Music]
it's time to fight for titles the best
juniors girls and Senior chess players
converge in the chess capital of America
St Louis Missouri for the U.S junior
girls and Senior championship
beginning July 15th 30 players will
compete across three fields for over a
150 000 prize fund
this tournament features the top Junior
and senior chess players in the nation
including the young up-and-comer Karissa
yip
returning Junior Champion Christopher
you and returning senior Champion
Alexander shavalov
three titles are on the line and you
won't want to miss it catch all the
action on the St Louis chess club
YouTube and twitch channels
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
it's your move
uni premiere of Chess plays the muni
through July 11th sponsored by St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame for ticketsmuni.org
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomed chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions and our Galleries and sign
up for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
q-boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
thank you hello everyone and welcome
back and after round one we have our
standings let's take a look we had three
decisive results Magnus Carlson young
Christoph dude and Richard report won
their games Richie's victory over Fabi
that was quite a surprise and a couple
of draws couple of draws Fury
and lupulasco Drew their games and Fabi
Yan and kukesh will try to make up for
the first loss exactly tell us about how
they're going to do that for the
pairings for round two let's take a look
we have Magnus Carlson playing Ivan
saritch happy Carolina playing lupulasco
a non-plane rapport
Duda against firoza and gukesh against
the promise both dukesh and nepo looking
to bounce back after well disappointing
play with the white pieces and by the
way guys and gals we have to make our
predictions
ladies first uh I was thinking really
hard about this but I'm gonna go with
feroza we're putting a Blacklist on
Magnus of course we're saying well
Magnus is the number one player can't
pick Magnus
um this one is really tough because I
also want to go with uh one of the grand
chest tour participants and I have to
say I was really impressed by John
Christoph Duda in Poland I thought he
played a tremendous tremendous event and
it was only because Magnus was Magnus
but I'm going to go with Duda and Miro
uh jump in what is your pick to win the
event you you left me with no choice
because yeah the best options are taken
or banned in case of Magnus well I go
with the Fabi even though even though he
lost this his game in game one but still
I trust him
all right and uh Dennis uh in the truck
uh Dennis Burris he's going to go with
Richie wondering about Anastasia and
Christian I think Christian picked
feroza as well oh okay so we'll have to
uh wait on Anastasia's pick but uh there
you have it as we're getting ready for
round two and I must say uh for a moment
there it really looked like it was going
to be a black day
two black wins and then Bobby had a
chance right with the queen against The
Rook of minor piece I think at some
point Anand was better as well exactly
exactly
so uh Ivan sarich right with the king's
Indian yeah
and I was happy to see a lot of decisive
results
for sure as the players getting ready
for uh the second round looks like the
crowd was filing there as well
see Leonard Otis our official
photographer
Leonard has a site where you can go and
see thousands upon thousands of photos
they're really really impressive
website as Duda the white pieces against
Perugia World our pigs facing off did I
make the right choice well let's find
out
uh what stood out for you uh oh in their
head to head pretty close pretty close
and Rapid uh five wins for dudok for for
ferocia and two draws exactly as the
round is underway I have at the game uh
between Duda and faroujana grunfeld
Greenfield exciting by the way Miro
these days it's sort of like the king's
Indian kind of fell out of fashion but
in a very strange way so is the grunfeld
and it's
why why
did the groom sell fall out of fashion
mural
asking the tough questions are you right
well yes you're right asking the right
guy because I had no idea what to do
against the groomfield when I was active
player and I'm eager to find out but I
have no explanation yet maybe maybe
we'll learn after this game do die
against feruja with Bishop to D2 an old
line uh
I remember I I think it was well I'm
certain it was uh vessels mislav uh that
played Bishop to D2 and it always it
always struck me as somehow peculiar but
I couldn't actually put my finger on why
there was something strange about this
move and the idea is as simple as it
looks you want to meet Bishop G7 with
the move E4 and that after Knight takes
C3 you just want to play Bishop takes C3
so that the pawn on there there is no
Pawn on C3 rather there's a bishop on C3
so C5 can be met nicely with D5 when
your Bishop is on E3 just a second let
me just go back here
excuse me E4 I takes Pawn takes Bishop
G7 Bishop E3 this is all very nice C5
you would love to play the move D5 but
your Pawn on C3 is hanging now with the
bishop on D2
there is no Pawn on C3 hanging Bishop D2
C oops sorry uh a very sharp line what
happened
the C5 happened C5 then D takes C
give me the pawn bishop G7 and queen B3
by the way I think uh last time
groomfield was tested on the highest
level was the world championship match
between Anand and gelfand correct yes
yes that was 2012.
2011.
right yeah it sure feels that way uh it
it's been a long time nepo mdl mvl
stopped playing the group though started
playing Queens Gambit accepted and what
does theory teach us about uh well just
second hold on Queen B3
I wanted to ask about Knight take C3 but
what am I saying Knight takes C3 just
simply Bishop takes E3 I don't can
blackfy Bishop B6 and sacrifice on B7 I
feel like that's the Gambit line that
it's probably the theory I don't play
grenfold but it looks like the time the
way it goes yeah
yeah so if you take on
I
I'm struggling here okay yeah that was
my question right I'm struggling if I
just take the Rook where uh Bishops
hmm
I
think your queen is safe yes yes somehow
it is right that is really peculiar
um so Queen to B3
so Bishop I mean you want to play the
move Bishop to E6 don't you
the E6 Queen takes B7 only if I'm
prepared to do it like I've done my
homework yeah right you're not playing
that move at the board exactly
right
uh help us out on this one we're
struggling a bit to uh justify the pawn
sacrifice after the move Queen B3 uh and
we do have by the way Knight F6 already
on the board
uh is this all the dictates a theory
that we're in
uh while judging by the speed players
played it it's theory for them at the
very least right right uh well as far as
I remember C5 was played quite a few
times when this line was popular and
this is uh what uvasa mentioned when it
was played in the world championship
match
uh right and I'm trying to recall yeah
so dc5 is certainly the move uh black
would play Bishop to G7 and I'm
wondering if Queen B3 was uh the move
that they were playing yeah after Queen
B3 you you were right that Bishop E6
apparently doesn't work so they just
play Knight F6 castle and I think that
that's pretty much what every gruntful
player does they just develop the pieces
you know the bishop G7 is very strong
some initiative and then with white you
keep wondering what does he have for the
pawn and at the same time it's very
awkward to develop right and then once
again how do you continue from here if
you go E4 well some weaknesses you know
on D4 and so on if you go E3 you
restrict your own UPS after Castle you
restrict your own Bishop on D2 so it's
all awkward uh computer has it after
Castle computer has it as better for
white uh substantially better up to
point eight so kind of almost a pawn
right but it's too early to judge I'm
afraid and black knows what he's doing
it seems like all right thank you for
that Miro I always laughed about Peter
Fiddler Peter whenever he was playing
the groom felt if he wasn't a pawn down
he wasn't happy he was like he was
gambiting everything let's take a look
at the game of gookash and nepo uh for a
moment as the both of these players are
looking to bounce back after their first
round loss uh Bishop F4 and London
system C5 D5 D6 Knight C3 and the
players have transposed into a Czech
benoni where well black is picking up a
Tempo with this uh E5 now Bishop G5
Bishop E7 and I was always very proud of
myself
whenever I could sneak in a tactic like
Knight takes D5 but Bishop takes F6
Bishop takes F6 giving up the dark
squared Bishops you kind of think that
that should be in Black's favor kind of
unusual benoni yes very much so so and
B5 on passan takes takes Rook A2 okay
that is a very good pawn and it's worth
defending
F5
H4 and wow
such a messy position already yeah it's
totally but I do see that if if I do get
to play the move Bishop H3 Rob black of
the two Bishops
um and get a good night on e4 I'd be
very very pleased with the white
position H4 Bishop d8 I don't know when
we left Theory
but this is this is a very strange world
what do you think of it and Miro jump
over uh and tell us about the Magnus uh
position
uh yeah so Magnus facing Ivan sarich and
yeah once again much higher rated
expected to score a full point or two
points in this case if you're talking
rapid right and hence the opening Choice
an English opening and a very very uh
say slowish positional system so it
started with C4 G6 and answering yasa's
remark about King's Indian being extinct
from the tournament practice
even sarish he did play the Kings Indian
in the first round and then that he has
a double block he repeats the color he
was going for the Kings Indian again uh
okay so symmetrical I think it's called
symmetrical English right up to the
point black repeats the moves and yes if
you if you're interested guys you can go
in detail on why you shouldn't repeat
the moves all the time and queen D2 is a
mysterious move right and I remember as
a kid when I've seen this first I
thought it's yeah some beginners are
playing the queen in front of the bishop
it has a point of protecting the Knight
and then later on in the game the very
next move it's B3 to develop the bishop
on Long diagonal Knight G7 Bishop B2
castles E3
and Knight G2 very flexible development
and we get in two more moves we get the
picturesque position of the F4 just look
at White's bone structure very flexible
and somewhat reminds you of so-called
fabias when chess was not chess but
satranch right the game played in India
with somewhat different rules uh well
the game would develop so slow that they
had to invent the starting positions
that they would not start with what we
know nowadays A starting position and it
would look very similar so you move the
pawns you try to control the center you
develop the pieces behind the pawn set
he he does everything very very well
after F4 black
uh well doesn't have a nice way of
resolving this tension because whenever
you capture white has a very pleasant
Choice he can take with the g-pawn and
then amass a huge center right Knight
we'll go to G3 or alternatively there is
always an option of capturing on F4 with
the Knight and then jumping to D5 so not
much to say just yet but I think it goes
uh the game goes the scenario of what
Magnus was planning to
okay uh thank you for that I jump into
the game between Fabi and
um
uh intriguing position and I kind of
just it took my breath away after the
move Knight C6 Bishop B5 is really
surprised I don't
quite understand why he played Bishop
takes C3 exactly here but Bishop takes
E3 Queen right yeah I think well hold on
yeah right it's a strange transposition
with H5 though I'm not familiar with
that move uh more familiar with the
moves Knight to E4 and c5h5 queen B3
Knight C6 and in this particular case we
get to play with our nice Center
Bishops of opposite color and you've
committed yourself to playing G5 and H5
is black I'm not
I I would think that white is to be much
preferred but stage four which I've seen
similar ideas because I applied the
ragos in with black H4 Bishop B5 Rook H6
I've done those kinds of things
I understand and I think that it's kind
of necessary as black that you play H4
because if white gets an H4 and you're
forced to play G4 well then I get the
beautiful f-score F4 squares and output
so H4 were kind of a required move and
now you're saying Bishop E5 Rook H6 yeah
these these types of uh
moves uh
97.
wow black is actually fine
wow I just I'm kind of stunned they
might not get away
because you play it with black right I'm
kind of stunned that you can get away
with this uh
well why it's behind in development
that's why
still able to develop the Knight and
castle
why am I behind in development just a
second what have I got I've got one two
guys you've got one two three but it's
my turn so I couldn't be that far behind
in development right
okay so if I play for example Knight
here give 97 meet the pawn Knight to D7
that's right
do you want to Castle short or long
that's the question yeah I think I want
a castle
chord in this case and I'm just looking
at a peace sacrifice which is a little
bit uh strange
your king is still yeah King's in the
center but uh if I can take on E5
quickly play 27 and Castle right life is
good right life is very very good in
this case
but we'll keep an eye on this one and
turn it over to you Miro as you've been
looking at the sheet it's a game
yeah now I'm a bit a little bit sad
yesterday that I didn't pick Vichy after
all he was doing very well in game one
and here as well yeah looks like he
might get an opening advantage against
which against Richie Robert
um well it used to be called rosalimo
Sicilian but I'm afraid by now we have
to call it the main line Sicilian
because D4 nobody seems to be interested
in right e76 C to C3 and well a very
logical but somewhat of a rare move
already
D5 e takes Queen D5 so it's sort of a
hybrid between the rosalima Sicilian
what we call the rosary musilian
development of the bishop to B5 and uh
C2 C3 all up in Sicilian or svenik of
Sicilians vashnikov uh Grandmaster
smashing have done a lot to popularize
and develop the theory of this one so we
here we have the mixture because if it
would go through C2 C3 moves or the
bishop B5 is probably not the best move
but on the other hand still white is
hoping to get something out of it Bishop
to D7
rookie one Knight to F6 and Bishop F1 is
well not the move that you expect to be
played but Bishop has nothing to do on
B5 it turns out and it stops white from
playing D2 D4 the one that he did
exactly on the very next move so now if
white would play D4 one with early after
C takes D4 the bishop B5 would have been
hanging right so Castle's short
interestingly
uh if black would have taken on D4
usually if we are talking a lap in
Sicilian once again the one with c2c3
white does not recapture but goes for
some tricks like going Knight A3 to B5
and so on and so on here computer
suggests you just take you develop the
Knight on C3 you get to some
isolated phone position and apparently
the wishbone D7 is not very well placed
computer still has it as roughly equal
but if you follow the lines black
somehow spends a lot of time uh bouncing
the queen around so it's not to
everyone's liking
so black has played Castle short and now
I wish you can just go Bishop D5 or even
what's interesting capture on C5
well black will have to trade the Queens
Bishop takes and this seemingly harmless
end game is still somewhat more pleasant
for white
I'm still uh catching up with you on
that one yeah it feels that way uh
looking at the game of gookash and and
nepho for just a moment because this has
been a chaotic game we're starting uh
with the whole opening and this check
benoni type of uh position that occurred
after F5 H4 Bishop H3 I was really
warming up to White's position uh so
many weak light squares in Black's
position C5 C4 okay there's some
ideas that F2 might be weak Queen E2
defending also protecting uh almost all
black pieces on the last rank exactly I
got a Fisher random position Queen C5
Knight F3 uh Bishop a A5 and 92. this is
uh this is a question that I wanted to
post to you
um Nasi I really like this move Knight
G5 and the idea behind Knight G5 of
course is I want to take the square E6
under control but I really would like
you oops excuse me I was going to give
my I have to toss in Bishop takes H
Bishop takes C8 first to take something
away from the F2 square and I get to
play Queen takes E4 with a Tempo against
H7 really good for white exactly what if
I allow you to play 96 so I play H6 yes
and this is this is where I wanted to
take the Dual advantage of the uh Pawn
on H4
so I was thinking of the peace sacrifice
Bishop takes you're just really eager to
sacrifice it I don't know I woke up this
morning
it's not my pieces so I could get rid of
them Bishop takes I didn't know if my
Rook on uh on the H file was going to
bring me uh
great success
exactly
and the whole idea of Queen H5 and splat
I think if you take on a five after Rook
F5 you still have to watch the F2 Square
I know that's the problem
yeah maybe I'm just being a little bit
too uh flippant with my uh peace
sacrifice Bishop uh Bishop A5 Knight D2
on the board and apple took two two
three yes took on C3 Bishop takes Pawn
takes so he's going towards the C4 Pawn
and he's hoping I guess to be able to
pick up the pawn on D5
I mean if you just allow us to play
Queen takes it's like game over right so
if we take Knight takes yes exactly
who's hanging here so exactly this is
the uh this is a recurring problem and
at night takes E4 Knight takes E4 Queen
takes D5
yeah maybe just Castle
maybe just Castle Bishop G2 first oh I
hang the bishop Bishop Bishop to G2
first okay intriguing and uh Mira I'd
toss it over to you as you've got the
Magnus uh game on your board
all right I have Magnus gamepad as well
I have to tell you that your analysis
once again guys spot on and nepo is in
trouble
uh right as for Magnus uh just a few
more moves and his Advantage begins to
crystallize so to speak so F4 as I said
not threatening just yet but it's very
awkward for black to play uh he replies
which seems to be an obvious yeah you
play a four a player five fight for the
center already turns out to be not the
best after Knight to D5 and here perhaps
yeah Bishop E6 would have been more to
the point than Bishop D7 Rook a E1
and here once again one hard thing in
chess is to what we call keep the
tension right you have so many
attempting captures for black and the
movie you had to play was either Queen
to D7 or Rook to F7 and as for Queen D7
at least from Human perspective I can
understand what it means right I'm
connecting the Rooks maybe planning Rook
28 Rook F7 like if someone would tell me
Rook F7 is a good move in this position
I wouldn't be able to tell why right and
Knight D5 a natural capture turns turns
out to be a mistake because of the C
takes night before we have this position
on the board the Knight on B4 is really
really misplaced so now White's supposed
to get Knight C3 he is threatening to
trap the Knight with a2a3 so A5 is
sort of forced and then you go A3 anyway
Knight ends up being on A6 and white
oops ends up on A6 and I just picks
picks the pawn on B5 it's a good Pawn
yeah it's it's a big question if black
has enough compensation he suddenly has
some because of like B file is open you
know the B Tree Pawn is potential Target
but bone is the pawn right
speaking of Pawns being pawns um taking
a look at the game between Duda and Ali
razor and first of all uh dude is grab
the pawn they just said you played C5 I
took the pawn on C5 RNA then
alireza played 85 which okay kind of
confused me Knight went to C6 Bishop E2
Bishop E6 and he's saying take another
Palm
and uh I mean I certainly have gotten my
hand caught in the cookie jar on more
than one occasion uh but Queen takes B7
I'm sorry I don't see the refutation
don't be afraid of let's say night
before well how is your queen going to
get out well exactly so I see that I
need to uh make room as I'm a little bit
afraid after the move night before that
you might actually just play Knight D3
check and not let you Castle yeah and
you get compensation with the light
Square so I'll I'll kill two birds with
one stone I'll give my queen an extra
retreating Square F3 but I'll also take
away Knight D3 and by the way uh I'll
introduce a threat of sorts with Knight
takes E6 uh intriguing moment going on
here between Duda and alireza but let's
jump uh to Zagreb and Christian
Christian Jump Right In what do you have
for us
a lot of exciting games are happening
guys but I do want to highlight uh one
particular one and that is the one
between karwana and one of the wild
cards the Romanian champion lupulasco
because I have to say lupuscu is taking
a very courageous route he's playing one
of his uh pet lines against Fabiano
Fabiano's pet lines against Fabiano uh
let's take a look at what happened in
the opening and let's remind one
critical game key game from Tata steel
earlier in January 2023 between Richie
report and Fabiano caruana and this was
exactly the same opening with H6 G5 and
H5 a very aggressive way of playing with
the black pieces you just want to push
the pawns uh you're saying that most
likely I'm not going to Castle on the
king side because I'm I already pushed
my hng pawns you're not taught as a
beginning player to uh push your Pawns
in front of you of your castle and this
is exactly what's not going to have one
most likely you're going to Castle on
the other side as black let's take a
look and queen two B3 was Fabiano's
Choice instead of that Richie played the
move H4 and I'll give you some insights
we did analyze this position because we
knew that Richie is very likely to play
at this line we did analyze this
position quite extensively
um I I gave Fabi quite a significant
file in this one so he definitely back
in the days knew what he was doing that
was in January he might have forgotten
some details uh since uh since then it's
uh what like six months ago something
along those lines so definitely uh the
knowledge is blurry in his mind but he
remembers some details surely H4 Knight
to E4 Queen to B3 was the game that was
played between Richie report and Fabiano
and after Knight to it I think it was
Knight to uh g3n I have to say Fabi did
not have any issues equalizing at that
game in fact he was even better at one
point the game ended up in a draw but
let's take a look at what happened in
the game once again Fabi chooses a
different option Queen to B3 not H4
first Knight to C6 and Bishop to B5 and
this is where he spent a large portion
of his time after Bishop takes C3
because btec C3 is a very significant uh
alternative to Queen takes C3 as well
you're wondering what why would I take
with the pawn well later on
um once I play the move C4 as white I'm
potentially going to get a very powerful
Center for example let's say Bishop to
D7 and then C4 take take with the queen
on C4 now you can see my Center is very
very powerful as why this is what white
is envisioning in this type of positions
and then later on in the end game maybe
after the change of the Queens I'm going
to start to push my points E4 E5 E4 D5
things of that nature and try to take
advantage of my majority but that did
not happen he decided to take with the
queen and now we have this position and
I was talking about a courageous way of
playing for black and I have to say
right now it seems like this is paying
off for uh black for Luke because it
seems like after a long Castle I was
saying from the beginning you will not
short Castle but I'm going to Long
Castle I'm going to get the other Rook
from d8 to E8 I'm going to put a lot of
pressure on the E file and I have to say
where is White's counter play you don't
have any Targets on the queen side that
pawn on C7 well the C file is blocked
because of my bishopon C6 so that
bishopone C6 despite the fact that it
looks like a pawn for the moment it's a
very strong piece it's a very strong
defensive piece and I have a clear
Target as black that pawn on E3 I'm
going to Triple down on the e-file and
I'm the one that's dictating the pace of
this game I have to say kudos to lupuscu
for picking an option an opening option
that Fabi himself has played in very
important games guys back to you in the
city thank you Chris and indeed that's a
very intriguing Bishops of opposite
color middle game uh jumping to the game
of Magnus for just a second because
after takes on D5 Knight B4 uh Mira was
showing as a very nice variation of
Knight C3
A5 A3 and just grab the pawn uh no
Magnus came up with a completely
different idea and a very visual idea he
said okay go ahead and take my Pawn on
A2 takes takes and this move Knight F4
very beautiful yeah it looks really
really attempting to not play it once
you sit right and that's uh that's I
think what Drew magnus's eye to uh this
whole concept he's threatening 96 which
is simply crushing if we get the a night
on E6 versus a knight on E2 takes takes
takes their
uh Magnus wins back the piece he's got
this very nice Center whether or not he
gets to play E5 and D6 in the near
future we'll see hghc Queen G5 check
King G8 and uh Evon I don't know but uh
he's kind of he's in here with a shout I
I would say uh for sure and you know
capturing that pawn on B5 versus playing
Knight I'm an F4
um
I think he's fighting back white spawn
structure is not that great of course E4
D5 Point chain is fantastic but right we
have three backward pawns like B3 D3 G3
so if White's attack is not successful
then black should be completely fine and
by the way Queen takes G3 on top uh for
Evon I just also wanted to jump in with
Vichy for a moment because uh even
though it's been a very very slow way of
play for white White's played Bishop B5
Bishop back to F1 you got the isolated
Queen Pawn positions where the Knight on
E5 and these are always kind of
dangerous for the second player because
you're looking at ideas like this and
this and Bishop G5 how many ideas right
uh so Bishop C6 Bishop F4 Bishop B4 and
we've caught up to the play and well
it's easier to play for white I think so
too I think so but objectively should be
close to equal yeah but in Rapid
if it's easier to play that's a big
Advantage yeah and you have the
initiative but Miro uh jumping uh over
passing the ball to you as we say uh
what's caught your eye in the second
round of play
yeah well there is a lot going on right
this game that you just discussed but
once again computer has something to say
it's not me I would wholeheartedly agree
with you yes and indeed it was close to
equality until the last move which
happens to be not the best but
interestingly computer claims that you
had to take and this is something that
you're not voluntarily doing and
apparently after Pawn takes you also
have to play the Intermezzo first to
make sure that the queen is not going
towards the uh towards the king side and
only then you go Knight D5 but yeah I
agree Bishop B4 is such a natural move
and then A3 which was played yes Bishop
takes Pawn takes and it happens to be
very dangerous for black all of a sudden
right and let us find out together why
Queen C3 is a bad move it's because of
Knight C4 and the queen is getting
caught on the very next move
hello right and then if he was if he
Richard was planning to capture on C3
and then you know just this realization
last moment ah okay I cannot take this
Pawn then yeah you might find it not
enjoyable because now you have to play
play a rook move F to the a to a to C8
let's say we do this one and then white
has well instead of having the isolated
Pawn white has uh so-called hanging
pawns right but a very very good
material for that so with hanging pawns
you usually want a lot of minor pieces
right so you have the space Advantage so
your opponent's pieces are not very well
placed yeah Queen to B3 then planning to
go see 3c4 sometimes looks very
promising for a nun
exactly uh that was the question that I
had uh one Pon for Duda in well he took
a second one and he did follow up night
B4 with Knight D4 which addressed the
threat of giving his Queen more squares
and also stopping Knight D3 uh
introducing 96 as well Rook B8 I think
Queen A7 is the only move because if you
play Queen F3 which was my intention
Bishop G4 exchanged in your white
squared bishop and then D3 square is
very weak tender and again you will lose
castle Yeah the option that that is a
very very good point and I could capture
on E6 right I mean I but in this case my
queen
is walking into a potential it's too
dangerous yeah uh it feels that way but
he did play Queen after Rook B8 he did
play Queen A7
and the idea is any Rook A8 I'll go
Queen B6 I won't uh I mean I'm two pawns
to the good and now came Knight to D7
and well it's fortunate that C6 doesn't
win but Knight D4 Knight C32 Knight on
C3 to B5 yes
that looks really good now Duda has C7
Square for his queen as well very
important I think he is also threatening
c67 push yep there's still 96 options
yep
in a lot of trouble yes and I wanted to
say and I'm two pawns up I mean I've got
the initiative and I've got the material
in hand now A2 sorry Miro has something
for us yes uh Miro uh clear our cobwebs
because at the moment we're thinking
white is enjoying himself
uh while there's a lot of stuff happen
in a span of like three full moves I
remember you guys were discussing this
position of the bishop E6 right and
Yasser was advocating the game the move
in the game Queen takes B7 which is a
good move but even better would be to
just play Queen A3 say I don't want two
pawns I want one extra pawn and
comfortable Castle you know and Rook F
to D1 then and it's just it's just
better for white okay after Queen B7
Knight B4 is indeed the best move Knight
D4 is one of the options Rook B8 Queen
A7 and here even though yes you were
absolutely right by the way after Queen
F3 Bishop G4 computer already favors
black a lot wow uh right but even after
Queen A7 it tends to be that the move
was nevertheless the gold Bishop G4
and this is the way you get contemplate
because after castles as far as I
understand you do not have a comfortable
way of dealing with
uh threats E5 you'll have to take and
then he takes on D4 it's a mess but
black kind of happy with this mess and
Knight D7 was just just a terrible
blunder it seems because of the Knight
cb5 the best you can do it seems that to
go through to A8 the queen C7 allow the
queen straight and white is not even
insisting on insisting on trading the
Queens it's just that means he has it in
his pocket all the time right and if I
would tell you that in this position
according to machine once again you can
probably see yourself the best move is
to trade your Pride and Glory Bishop
takes D4 and you understand the position
is bad I mean if you have to play Bishop
takes D4 here and you not winning a
piece that means is better yeah Bishop
takes D4 is not one of those moves that
comes uh with flow you know if you give
me 10 candidate moves Bishop D4 wouldn't
be one of them but yeah not at all uh
seriously all across the board uh some
very intriguing games uh jumping to the
game of good cash and a Napa for just a
moment uh when we left it we left it in
these parts after I think position was
looking very good very good right about
here takes and here I think our Focus
had been mainly on before Knight takes
season 5 and then Bishop G2 is what we
looked at exactly uh Knight takes E4
Queen takes D5 Bishop G2 with the idea
of scaring something along this diagonal
uh
a good guy started with uh Bishop G2
giving himself an option of even
capturing this Pawn on a C4 and Bishop
F5 G4
Knight takes E4 Queen back Queen takes
C4 and at first it looks like good cash
is just doing really really well
until you saw this movie so much anymore
and now it's not so uh convincing uh we
do have Queen B7 seeking to trade Queens
but I'm supposed uh Queen C4 threatening
mate in one
is I have to play between B5 yes exactly
Queen C4 Queen B5 well I'd rather trade
Queens on B5 than on B7 why invite the
The Rook
um but uh first impressions are that
white had something huge a moment ago
and maybe not So Much Anymore Miro how
how does the engine evaluate the game
well in current position once again
you're absolutely right and current
position is the position on the board
not the one that I had right uh yeah
after Queen B7 it seems that yes both
sides have to accept this repetition I'm
not sure if they will but yeah that's
that's the best uh that position has to
offer Queen B5 and as a black you don't
want to trade Queens because your pawns
down as white you well don't want to
Castle because it's dangerous yeah the
king is weak but there is a certain but
to this one after fe4 you were
absolutely right yes sir Nasi Knight E4
would be devastating for black
devastating on D5 Bishop G2 and you
might as well resign I mean you go King
h8 and somehow mystically not losing
immediately because the bishop is not
protected but then off the castles you
have to play Bishop B7 and white goes
Rook B2 and it never stops right Bishop
C6 Rook to D1 then capture on D6 that
just falls apart all all white bases
joining the action all of a sudden so
Bishop G2 practically drops the
advantage and at some point you'd be
surprised Queen takes C4 and nepop play
day five and he missed a chance to play
for a huge Advantage here with Bishop B5
and once again uh the stuff I was
telling well a few minutes ago when
computer move is played on the board you
immediately identify what's the point
the point is that if you move the queen
Rook takes F2
wow that's the problem but you're not
looking at it right I mean you're not
looking at it when when it's not played
on the board and then yeah if the Rook
is on F2 you have to take and it's a
check you know and it's a Checkmate
Bishop E2
yeah how to Checkmate yeah Bishop F3 he
starts Queen to C1 take the Knight gives
a check checkmates on G2 at the very end
so Bishop B5 I'm not saying it would
have won the game but that was a very
unpleasant surprise and white would have
to shape up and find Rook B2 already not
an obvious move right and then after
Knight D7 the threat is the same the
queen is protected if you move the White
Queen group takes F2 is going to happen
so you had to take on B5 ab5 go Queen C6
where black is already better black
holes red he's up material white is not
without the without the chance but right
yeah that would turn the game upside
down wow for sure recap too
ouch that would have hurt for those of
you who are joining as late shame on you
where have you been but these are our
standings after round one let's see we
had three players win the first round
Magnus Carlson Jan Christoph to the
enrich Rapport we had two draws between
ferozanand and sarich lupulasco
and three players trying to catch up in
round two and let's just jump into the
tiger Madras for a moment as he's up
against uh Richie before Vichy uh
grabbed the pawn something near and dear
to my own heart he played Queen takes B7
Knight to uh D5 with ideas of his own
hitting the bishop and
let's say Bishop D2 which is the move
you want to play Quinn doesn't have
anywhere to go but he have an in-between
move right I have Knight C6 but I also
have nights before maybe well this
it's not the same thing if I go Knight
C6 you're you're obliged to take aren't
you
take and then Rook F2 C8 maybe right and
we get this position I still have a
square fortunately for my queen I still
have Queen to D6 and maybe a rook B2
here
it's it's interesting can I just it's
sort of like I've got the two Bishops
you know I just want to keep your
initiative on hold for just a moment but
Rook the B2 is annoying
that's very annoying maybe Knight C4 was
actually better yeah maybe Knight C4
right back at the very start Queen takes
B7 he's played Bishop D2 by the way so
uh
this line that we're as contemplating is
a very likely one Knight to C4
so if we take
we take we drop in
I can come back and I'd say four if I
have to
um
night night comes back to C4 just in
time okay that's a big difference and uh
Miro jump in on this one uh I I was
having a difficult time between Knight
C6 and Knight C4 yeah but I think Knight
C4 uh maybe convince me yeah right
Knight C4 is the good move in this
position it's the key move in various
lines that I was able to find but yasa
first before that what you said uh when
you said Queen has nowhere to go the
reason A6 Square surprisingly well white
is still much but
yeah we're just not used to see the
bishop on F1 I believe like in all these
structures Bishop is either present on
D3 or non-existent at all yeah that's
why we had hard time identifying Queen
A6 uh yeah so after Queen A6 White's
better but Knight C4 is yeah
even stronger and White's close to
winning and same night C4 by the way
works if black attempts to take the
pawns yeah that would be Knight C4
inches winds material so all in all uh
for now capturing the pawn on B7 seems
to be a good thing yeah DOTA is winning
and Vichy vishi has a huge advantage and
let's just check in on Magnus because
that was that whole visual uh line of
Knight F4 that Magnus played uh I think
he's got a good attack going right now
he has the openg file okay after Queen
G5
in order to protect this Pawn on G3
Magnus started with a check
and then play Queen to E5 defending the
pawn on G3 nice probably threatening
Queen C7 ideas yet and by the way
vis-a-vis the pawn on F5s in a pin Queen
C7 and queen so he induced the move Rook
F7 because in some lines Rook on E8 can
be hanging
gotcha it's the touch of the Grand
Master right uh Queen uh back G4 and
also in some lines The Rook on F7 can be
hanging G4 Rook over takes takes and
we've caught up to the players and what
are the clock Times by the way should we
have few more moves on the board
so Yvonne's down to five minutes and
maglu still has 11 minutes so twice as
much time looking pretty good for Magnus
exactly I'm I'm trying to get the uh
pawns to run down the board can I
can I start with G6 yeah pardon me uh D6
I mean I'm assuming you have to take
uh he did play Rook on F1 to F3
yeah and he is covering G3
it's not a tactic that you're used to
seeing that after takes you get to play
Queen takes F7 check right I mean
normally you know you don't you don't
have this pattern but Rook F3 I assume
that if he had started with the move D6
there was Rook G3 Queen G3 Rook G7 and
so that was why Magnus played Rook on F1
to F3 first and some moves have been
played Bishop C8 played by sarich now D6
is looking pretty good
definitely uh the uh if think White's
problem here is that he has too many
good moves right he has to pick
sometimes it's really helpful when you
have a very clear path and it's a narrow
one here you're right I mean Magnus does
have some very nice options including D6
feels good for
the number one player Magnus uh mirror
with it do we got it right
Magnus for Choice uh yeah it's it's
Magnus for Choice yeah let me like let
me get his position back up right right
well some slight improvements here and
there but overall it seems that it's get
this equal position according to
computer which was more pleasant to play
with white from Human standpoint and
guess what it developed it to a better
position
right so after Rook F7 for whatever
reason computer would prefer to take on
G7 first and then to go Rook F3 after
Rook F3 some strange recommendation but
pretty much after Bishop C8 which is one
of the best moves white is still better
and I just received this move D6 which
I'm not sure is a good move yeah well it
is white is still better right what's
puzzling to me is computer insists in
many lines
on playing A6 A5 and then once again I
mean it's no not anymore not anymore so
something has changed right not anymore
yeah I think yeah computer also
sometimes gets tired at least our studio
computer days yeah looks very promising
for Magnus you were absolutely right and
I have some little announcement yes sir
if you if you let me where was the yeah
do this game do this game and let me go
to night before where we afraid that the
screen might get trapped right guess
what in five moves he is Queen up
so we've seen this we said Knight cb5
and it's really hard for black to find a
good way of playing and for Roger girls
Knight A2 basically going all in
allowing Knight C6 without a plan to
move the queen queen is attacked but he
just captures on C1
takes back the Knight on d8 Bishop takes
Rook 8.
uh well get some initiative but let's be
fair it's a queen for a rook so there's
minimal accuracy why it should convert
it in a whole point wow wow that would
be a great start for Duda as it would be
a second
and we have first result in round two
kukesh and nepalny she have drawn their
game we did expect this repetition as
neither yeah as neither player could uh
avoid it you didn't want to castle with
white uh in this position uh so thanks
for both players miss their chances in
this game as we were looking at that
have really felt like gukash had uh
really stopped the game the best chances
uh jumping to the game of Fabi for a
moment because this was the game that
Christian had pointed out that uh black
had this
wild for black yeah and his pressure
down the e-file against the upon on E3
was
especially uh nettlesome I want to say
uh F5 Queen A5 by the way
either as far as the puzzle Rush tactics
is concerned that is a that's a funny
one you don't see a threat of check
meetings walked in there like it doesn't
exist exactly exactly it's kind of this
hidden guided missile on H2 uh Knight B6
uh ideas of Knight C4 B2 B3 dealing with
those Rook takes E3 Bishop E5 and this
exchange sacrifice uh normally speaking
this should be very good for black I
mean I wouldn't want to enter this kind
of position myself
but the political lost the D3 Pawn which
has oh very important in the attack that
was hurtful that was hurtful let's see
just a second Rook takes E5
because that could have been Pawn number
two to begin with right Queen takes E5
I have early here yeah just
I I mean I'm assuming upon on A7 is not
uh
needed for the attack but he played D4
Rook D1 D3 Knight f
to concentrate on the king side now so
maybe Rook G8 and just throw pieces on
the king side everybody is going over
that away
because I'm down a lot of material but I
still have play on the king side yeah
well my king especially uh he took on F3
something similar to what you're
suggesting Nasi but he I like your Rook
G8 to keep the options open yeah well to
keep the pieces on the board but here I
suppose black is banking on the idea
that he's got a check it's Fabi took
back immediately on F3 and then he
played Rook G8 okay well
um excuse me not Rook G8 takes first
takes now Rook G8 now we've got to deal
with the
these threats right I mean bad things
can happen Queen D2 maybe Queen D2 it's
probably too passive I just wanted to
stop Queen G5 but you have Queen G7
options as well
my king might be going for a March and I
I'm not sure
um
okay so uh one one I didn't uh maybe
it's weird yeah it's just way too slow
you're just you're just coming in really
fast uh I don't have E7 and queen now uh
queen of five
and uh by the way let's just jump back
to the game of Vichy for a moment
because Richie could be in serious time
trouble he only has 12 seconds oh
and a bad position he's down two pawns
and it's an end game Bishops versus
Knights the rules are still on the board
but well it's funny because his whole
career that she's been playing vishes
the one who's plays with the Knights
right so it's very strange to see vishi
with the two Bishops and the problem is
he plays with the two Bishops really
really well as uh he just prefers nights
he just prefers nights and by the way
that those seconds were ticking down
as Richie played the move room even if
Richie had time here I think his
position is completely lost
completely lost 90 cents like at the
moment why the position looks passive
but it's very temporary yeah and these
pawns A4 A5 this bishop whenever you
take this Pawn on C5 uh Bishop can come
to E3 and Black's not really interested
in the pawn Knight too Richard just made
his last move with three seconds on the
clock
taken down was it there was a Richie
maybe it was here in St Louis uh and I
realized the master of making moves with
one one second on her clock right but I
think it was maybe with nepo
as uh he went down to a second here we
go
through the magic of time two seconds
one and eleven one and eleven yeah
10 second bonus so there was the one
second and Knight to D7 on the board and
again Richie's just going to be playing
struggling I would say uh
with
the increment at this moment
four seconds three seconds
yeah and it's very easy for vision to
play
well exactly just push the bonds away
keep pushing yeah
by the way this is also
yeah this is just too easy for for fishy
to play
is there any counter play if I give you
a C4 Pawn I'm still completely winning
but Anand doesn't even get they're okay
for I like that move by the way because
A6 would have allowed Knight C4 but just
keeping the pawns and playing for A6 at
a certain moment
F4 is going to maybe he can bring this I
can Rook right to B1 or D1 the open
files and exactly that will be game over
in fact Richie just played the move Rook
B2 to prevent Rook B1 but I loved your
idea of room to D1
and by the way I think Rook D once
threatens to win the piece with F4
love it and he's about to play it
one of the things is when you do have so
much more time than your opponent I'm
one of those players who
you know says you know take it easy just
use your time you don't have to get
caught up in the moment but uh Vichy is
playing all of these moves a la Tempo uh
well he's making the best moves
that's good Rook before Miro uh how big
an advantage is this uh according to the
engines
Miro
uh well I was I was trying to cover the
evaluation so you would not see me but
this since I'm only a voice in your head
let me tell you is plus seven for quite
a while already plus six seven yeah that
that's it I wouldn't have guessed it was
that high but plus seven wow maybe plus
three because we're up to pawns right
right we're plus seven and why is it so
yeah it's just that black if white paper
plays perfectly which which it does to
an extent black can never establish any
sort of coordination so now for instance
G3 is one of the moves suggested so you
only have one problematic piece which is
the bishop on F1 as long as it or as
soon as it appears on the long diagonal
the game's over right right G3 Bishop G2
nice and by the way there we go G4
serves the same purpose yes and Bishop
G2 sorry now should we stay with this
game
let's see how Magnus is doing exactly it
has very nice Central Pawns and in fact
he's pushing them he they're both in
time trouble Magnus down to three
minutes uh Yvonne down to two minutes
and H5 still kicking he actually has a
nice blockade Yvonne with black right
exactly the bishop is on E6
okay I like his last move H5 he's
putting pressure on the king side too
because
for for the longest time whites had
advantage on the king side and now
I don't know here we go H4 I have to
finally move the Rook from G3 it was a
great rug
you have to take you up to seven okay
let's let's have a look see
Magnus dropped a piece
Rook takes back
how does white improve since I can't
push the Palms forward I'm thinking
Queen F4 I have ideas of Bishop H if I
play Bishop H3 right away I'm afraid of
Queen G5 and you'll remind me and by the
way uh this the swanathon Vichy did win
his game against Richie and the the very
end yeah I think you just resigned G4
Bishop as as Miro said you put the
bishop on the long diagonal and as soon
as he played F4
uh well I mean Richie had seen enough uh
jumping again back to uh world number
one Magnus try not to call him Magnus uh
world champion uh uh
Rook G7 and Rook takes G7 so I was
thinking because Queen G5 looms so large
um
yeah we probably have to play defensive
move but after Queen F4 can I can I get
my queen to see let's say C8 and C2 or
yeah is that too ambitious I I began to
think that maybe I should play Queen to
F2 instead of Queen to F4 manifest Rook
F4 so maybe he plans to put the queen on
F2 exactly Queen G5 Queen F2 the thing
is white defended now
well I wouldn't say he's defending so
much as he just
he wants to break the blockade and if I
could ever play Bishop H3 and Bishop
takes F5
it's game over I mean you won't be able
to keep these pawns I think Yvonne
should play Rook H7 and defend the pawn
or just leave it hanging on H4
I hadn't gotten that far
you're too fast uh
I'm not sure Miro jump in uh the very
very tense as both players are just down
to minutes on their clock how does the
engines assess I mean I'm looking at
these pawns on E5 and D6 and I really
like magnus's position but I'm not 100
sure of his success right everyone's
looking for magnus's win he is looking
for it himself but let me tell you
something the win is not there the
position is equal despite this dangerous
looking pawns yeah and the ways the wind
was missed when he created the spawn
Center because after Bishop E6 which is
slight mistake but we are not going too
much into detail e takes F5 well a
simple move in in a way ugly looking
move would have just won the game on a
spot right and and you can't really do
much Bishop F5 white sculptures on uh
captures on G7 perhaps this is a little
trick you give a check on E5 give a
check on E5 and if Queen F6 you can
capture on F5 the queen is pinned so you
have to
yeah after E5 and we are currently
yeah Queen F2 quite a few moves were
okay four seems to be good enough yeah
it seems to be good enough so B takes B
takes
if Rook A4 yeah they actually go F4 and
you eliminate the E5 Pawn apparently and
and that will be it okay it looks like a
draw interestingly wow great defense
that'd be that'd be quite a safe yeah
that whole Bishop C8 Bishop E6
uh remarkable
and by the way we see that uh yanduda
has won when we left it he had a queen
for a rook and we thought well okay
pretty uh pretty clear so two victories
for the white pieces so far Magnus let's
check five Miss King exactly because we
have a lot has happened since we last
looked at it sure okay so when we left
it we saw this position with Rook G8 and
we said uh dangerous dangerous uh for
white
A6 A4 97
and what's the clock Times by the way
because this is a real police goes down
to just seconds 14 seconds really tense
position Bobby has about a minute
but I think Fabric's got everything
under control now well he just slurped
upon on C7 and he went Munch and he
retreated it came back nothing really
happening on the G file night on E2 is
just a great defender yes not only does
it protect G3 but also G1 so any time
black tries to play a move like Queen G7
or queen G6 I can meet it with Rook G1
Queen D4 and it feels like White's
consolidating his extra material I think
six okay queen of Fate quack you ideas
before checking idea
yeah in this position it is yeah he may
be uh down to actually having to play it
uh Knight to F4
yeah playing this
crazy position with a few seconds on the
clock is so difficult by the way Queen
f8 not an obvious move came almost
instantly it was like Queen B8 sorry uh
came almost instantly uh by the way uh
again both players down to about 30
seconds on their clock yes
what does the engine say is the white
winning
yeah yeah White's winning for quite some
time and the key move was Knight to E2
back when we were looking how to defend
against Black's gone to play when he
played Knight to E2 and that that was it
and now Fabi has everything under
control we just saw Knight takes B3 by
the way idea trapped
yeah I I was looking at the same thing I
saw Queen V4 Queen so I was thinking
Queen B6 and then Bishop takes oh 92.
93.
oh my god well Queen B6 was a bad move
and now he's no longer better wow
and he is playing that is to say
Constantine is playing incredibly
quickly for a check made 96.97 but after
Rook C8 defending the Checkmate Black's
also throwing a knight C4 Fork exactly
and that's a family
whoa oh almost on time
oh 94 but doesn't that invite Knight C4
I didn't say for this Knight C6 in
between move and then I have 94 is
winning for black now 94 as well
E4 check not that easy to spot but it
seemingly wins The Rook on E5 is hanging
20 seconds will he find 94.
well he's looking to play Knights C4
that's the problem and he yes he's
looking to play Knight C4 missing
opportunity with Knight E4 Bishop D7
five seconds three
black position still looks more solid
now oh Queen's coming to G3 that's what
it's all about Queen to G3 check
and Fabby just played F4 giving back the
exchange so black should be much better
now they got the material back and white
king is still extremely weak yeah but
Queen F4 and maybe E6 Queen H4 sorry get
rid of that pawn so that there's no
Queen G3 check I we played so fast he's
after
this afternoon
oh my queen C7 the queen did a great job
on B8
and we just heard a big update that
Magnus is actually losing his game wow
stay with this one but wow whoa very
quickly in time trouble welcome to Rapid
chats
Queen F4 so it's sort of like okay I'm
playing on the dark squares and maybe I
can use my H Pawn yes he's done it he's
just played Queen to F4 blockading and
now H4 and Fabi saying okay you're not
gonna play A5 A4 and open up your king
it's actually fascinating why the king
is completely open but I can't get to it
that's crazy okay Brooke that makes a
lot of sense Rook G8 uh sets up rook G4
I'm probably obliged to play what she
wants yeah
he's done we have it
yeah if Rooks come off like
yes it's not getting checkmated and
that's a good thing H5 so why sponsored
further pushed yeah things can turn
around again Fabi might still win this
and by the way that move Rook G1 was
challenging as Constantine said okay I'm
backing off I'm going to play Rook to d8
but is the inviting Rook to G7 as well
as H5
I'm more afraid of H5 and just age five
a little bit Rook G6 okay Rook G6 the
idea anytime you want to play Queen C5 I
can maybe interfere with amazing then
that this players can find the most
accurate moves with just 10 seconds on
the clock exactly speaking of 10 seconds
look at the
Magnus draw apparently save the game
and Yvonne looks a little bit uh
perturbed I would say he missed
something uh Rook D6 and Rook G8 Miro
I'm feeling this is a three result game
uh going on here and the clocks
are
wait whoa E6
well a lot of stuff happening better not
to ask for computer evaluation in this
one no it changes all the time by the
way what a move Queen G5 we just
are we going to The Rook ending well
I was thinking of Queen f8
but then there was E7 and that was like
embarrassing he said Queen A7 still wins
after queen h8 as well E7 the same Oh
What A Move that's a beautiful move and
I'm sure he's gonna find it yes Bobby is
a monster oh my goodness what a clever
move that is Rook takes G5 take my queen
Rook to d8 and white wins what a way to
win wow
remarkable campaigns Rook d8 well Rook
d8 is Bishop Y8 played with two seconds
on the clock
okay so it was Pawn stopped for now but
now I think it's black hold on we'll get
checkmated exactly Knight B5 check oh a
queen going to B8
there was gotta be a mate now
there was a knight B5 check and a queen
E3 check
still should be checked me right Queen
ba check now King B6 Queen D6 and
um yeah yeah exactly it's got to be we
don't know exactly we don't calculate it
we we just know it's there yeah but
definitely Queen B8 check let's go
zombies 10 seconds
attempting moves maybe Knight B5 right
away and he played none of them he
played
Queen G NG uncheck what is that it's
black this must be winning
he's holding by a threat somehow but but
yes no he's threatening Knight C6 double
Checkmate so you have no time to play
Rook G3 that's beautiful thread but
Queen B1 very good move well I can go
Knight C2 check Discovery Channel with
B6 oh I'm sorry you can't like that
that's one crazy game oh my goodness
still any any result is possible here
exactly but that move Queen E3 was
shocking
which check is correct now well Bishop
B5 check gets met by Knight takes B5
double check mate correct so that's a
movie and you don't see very often
double I can play F7 but you have 96.
and then I do have a check on DC White's
King is on C4s this is and no time King
to D5
that looks like a blunder
blunder alert
oh
uh it's the nerves of the ticking clock
do you have any checks that's a queen A2
check
three covers all
wow it's the night the the role of the
night in these positions it does such a
great job at defending the King and King
High
on D5 and I think that's Johnny ball
game
yeah
there's no
wow I actually thought when black played
the move Queen G1 check that Bobby had
just lost the game
well now it's definitely over
because the in-game no Perpetual checks
and the pawn on E7 is too strong yeah
wow Constantine is saying how did I lose
that I mean Miro how did he lose that uh
well that's one of those games indeed
that like when it's over like both
players have no choice but to laugh
because yeah we we all understand there
was a lot of lot of stuff happening
there I'm not even sure where to start
right exactly well let's just review uh
our results uh
but first of all let's jump to Zagreb
with Christian what around Christian my
goodness
wow
oh my God the energy here in the
building is absolutely palpable but I
have to say that game was absolutely
wild but take a look at what happened in
the game between Magnus and sarish
because at some point and you lost that
moment because you had to focus on the
game of Fabiano versus but at some point
Magnus was in fact losing in his game
against Yvonne saritch and let's take a
look what that moment was exactly and
this was the moment after the move
Bishop takes F5 things look under
control for both sides but still the
position remains complicated because as
black I have that pawn on A3 very very
threatening the pawn on G3 as well
supported by The Rook but of course
White's connected passers on the DNE
file those are extremely dangerous as
well take King to G2 Bishop to D5
uh Bishop to E4 Bishop to E6 Bishop to
F5 we repeat once and uh I have to say
Magnus is always so ambitious always
he's trying to find and a squeeze uh the
last energy from the position the the
last drop of energy from the position
and this is exactly what happened in
this game and he's also taking a lot of
risks with that rhythm of King to G1 in
fact this position right now for black
is winning take a look A2 first move
very very correct Rook to F1 and now G2
was not the correct move because what he
had to understand black that is Ivan
sarich is that with the bishop on D5 you
have an extra idea of potentially
checkmating the king via H1 and how do I
get to H1 can I go Rook to H7 no you
cannot because I'm going to take with
the bishop but what you can do is play
the move Rook to A7 that's threatening
to promote uh into a queen A1 Queen you
have to be defend against that you don't
have time to do anything else you have
to go Rook to A1 and now I have a couple
of moves but the plan is the same I can
go King to G7 or I can do Rook to A8 the
idea is you're going to go E6 you're
very threatening you're almost promoting
your pawns but you're not in time now I
go King to G7 D7 let's say and now Rook
to h8 and the game is over because you
don't have a way to protect against
Checkmate on H1 this is an absolutely
wild idea absolutely wild plan for a
black that surely it's extremely
difficult to find with little time on
the clock he did not do that he played
the move G2 and after that the position
just simplifies into a draw what a wild
round here in a Zagreb round two is in
the book the books and let's take a look
at the standings we have Yan shishtav
Duda who is absolutely dominating in
this event two victories Four Points
Magnus and with three points following
closely behind and after that with 50
Fabiano Richie report and Ivan sarich
guys I have to say what a tournament we
have so far we're going to go on a short
break and we have an interview with the
one and only Magnus cars
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Croatia glad to see you
here and you wrote in your Instagram
that it's one of your favorite cities
what is special about Zagreb I seem to
do very well when I play here
um but in general I like cities where
um well especially during summer where
you can
walk around exercise outside you know
beautiful old buildings good restaurants
and a general you know good holiday Vibe
yeah that's great and I was wondering
how many do you know how many times have
you won tournaments on granchester
do you have any record
uh
[Music]
I don't remember how many tournaments
I've won I have a feeling that in terms
of classical probably I haven't won that
many and in terms of rapid and Blitz I
think I've won most of the tournaments
that I've played wow but we can ask
Tarjay normally he has all the
statistics
um and one more question is you know
exactly one year ago you made this very
special announcement for the whole Chess
World which of course has its impact the
history of Chess you said that you're
not going to defend your title anymore
so one year has passed and my question
is um let's say um how do you feel about
it now after one year and what impact
has it had on your own life and on your
chess and motivation
I would say
um the
that it feels pretty similar as to what
it did last year and also uh before that
that I'd sort of mentally
checked out of the world championship
and
it feels good not to have to to worry
about it in terms of my motivation I
think now for for a number of years the
motivation has come and gone a little
bit and you can see that in some of the
tournaments that I I play
that sometimes
um you can sense that it's really really
important to me is other other times
tomorrow like yeah we'll see how it goes
and and then the the results often often
show that so I I think like you know
recently I haven't played so well but
I've had bad stretches
before and I'm definitely motivated now
to to strike back in this one yeah and
also you we could see you in the list of
the tournament of World Cup in Baku and
I think it's probably the only event
you've never won and do you have any
special motivations for this event as
well
so I uh I originally had other plans uh
during the times of the World Cup then
they didn't happen
um and it was actually during Norwich us
that I
that I thought thought about the
possibility of playing the World Cup at
all
um
and uh throughout the tournament there I
felt like I wasn't doing so well so I
was thinking that yeah it would be good
to get a chance to play some classical
chess again just to prove that I'm not
not as bad as I was as I was showing
there yeah I mean we're looking forward
for sure
for sure too and if I ask you like what
is the most memorable GCT event which
comes first to your mind
I think
[Music]
there there are uh there are a few uh
classical definitely Zagreb 29 2019 it
was uh yeah it was just a good vibe
overall and
um one of my very best uh classical
results
uh apart from that
uh I would say
I remember
2017 very well and um also Kolkata 2019
was was a lot of fun yeah also I
remember in Kolkata there were many many
people come in lots of fans and actually
we also witnessed the same here in
Zagreb and I just wanted to tell you
that there was one girl last year chess
fan who came here and she asked you for
autograph on her shoulder and next day
she has made tattoo from your with your
signature and I just wonder wondered
what do you think about it and if there
is any person in this world you would
like to have tattoo signature
on your body
no I don't have any tattoos currently
and I don't have any plans of it but I
think as for other people if you're
going to get a tattoo I think my
signature is not the worst wait wait to
uh deface your your body yep
we'll see what's happening this year and
actually expecting lots of people coming
and you are here from yesterday did
somebody catch you already for your
signatures for you know selfies like how
do you feel
yourself yeah I um
I I I I I I do you know when I'm walking
around I do get caught up by by chess
fans so
once in a while and
um most of the time it's they're really
nice and it's it's fine yeah okay all
the best of luck for in this tournament
and in the others as well thank you so
much thank you
[Music]
it's time to fight for titles the best
juniors girls and Senior chess players
converge in the chess capital of America
St Louis Missouri for the U.S junior
girls and Senior championship
beginning July 15th 30 players will
compete across three fields for over a
150 000 prize fund
this tournament features the top Junior
and senior chess players in the nation
including the young up-and-comer Karissa
yip
returning Junior Champion Christopher
you and returning senior Champion
Alexander shavalov
three titles are on the line and you
won't want to miss it catch all the
action on the St Louis chess club
YouTube and twitch channels
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the games the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out
q-boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
the beauty in Forest Park
it's your move
uni premiere of Chess plays the muni
through July 11th sponsored by St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame for ticketsmuni.org
foreign
chess club is the Premier chess facility
in the United States and is among the
best in the world thanks to co-founders
Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield and Rex
sinkfield the St Louis chess club is a
non-profit organization committed to
promoting the game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions and our Galleries and sign
up for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
thank you
hello everyone and welcome back after
two rounds these are our standings now
see the honors we already have a soul
leader young Christopher won both of his
games and then close the following
Magnus Carlson and vision and with three
points Legends uh type per second but
Magnus for a brief moment there was uh
vulnerable and then then we have with 50
Fabiano caruana Richard Rapport and Ivan
sarich wow a nice start and our pairings
for our third and final round of today
we have Neville against Carlson and we
imagine the World Championship Sunday
Dubai firosha against School cash both
these young players looking for victory
which report against the tournament
leader Duda lupulasco against Anand and
sarich versus caruana nice and as I
haven't been able to get to it because
we have been going to break at various
times but it's a good chance to check in
with our friends at Q Boutique and find
out
what's on special for today and it's a
gray men's jacket and it celebrates the
annual Grand chest tour makes the
perfect addition to any chess player's
wardrobe features the logo the grand
Chester on the top left of the jacket
and a full length zipper 60 cotton 40
polyester available at Q Boutique St
louis.com
that's a very accurate uh very
attractive jacket I like it a lot and
Miro uh after two rounds of play what
your what are your impressions uh well
it's all up and down as you could have
seen right I'm glad that Fabi finally
won that game but man that was a roller
coaster by the way yes since I'm dealing
with computer I'm not relying on my
memory but was young Christoph to the
yopik yes okay naturally naturally yes
yes well by strangers thank you for
asking he's the one leading the
tournament you see it's too early it's
too early yes if you don't mind could
you just point out that one moment that
the vulnerability of Magnus Yvonne
sarich The Local Hero yeah
right oops Yeah if you still have it on
oh yeah Carlson we have this position
here the final position with everything
vanished from the board right
you have to understand like Magnus was
better throughout the game right and a
couple of moves before he uh avoided the
repetition still being on the influence
that I'm better I have to win I'm
pushing for a win and then here would
Savage have played Rook to A7 it could
cost Magnus dearly because yeah A1 Queen
is the threat and when you go to when
you go to play Rook A1 computer shows a
very funny plan for black so it
basically starts with King G7 or Rook A8
in some order and the problem for white
is that when you play D7
black girls rook h8 and checkmates on H1
so it's a very nice geometric maneuver
right I mean Rook goes to A8 h8 like
basically all the corners of the board
and yeah white has some ways to fight
against it but black would be close to
winning would he have played Rook A7 so
Magnus was vulnerable
wow just for a brief moment wow and as
we saw in the fabianos game I mean that
was a three result game and both players
were just playing on this increments
with seconds and a lot of blunders in
that game very very very nerve-wracking
game uh for for for both players as we
get ready for round three and again uh
the pairings are just mouth-watering a
rematch of the world championship
between nepo and Carlson I call the
ambience in the plane Hall it's very
dark and then they highlight the chess
boards I love that I love that theater
like look where you get the spotlight
and you're there and it's the best
feeling when you have a big crowd uh I
think code that really threw a lot of
the players off everybody's at home
not in front of the crowds as they're
off
as our tournament leader uh Jan Kristoff
uh with the black pieces I against
Richie E4 and stop e4c5 stop Ricci won
the first game against Bobby then lost
to Anand yep and we'll see if he reaches
one of the players who doesn't make as
many draws as the other players right no
a he he's one of those uh players who
really likes uh you know swinging for
the fences D7 D6 an invitation
to a night off and uh so far uh the
players have been avoiding the open uh
Sicilian uh whether it be by playing in
a lap-in or Russell limo with C3 and 84.
by the way I think Magnus is late
because nepo played E4 and uh that's it
I saw him walking around in the plane
Hall as he's waiting yeah E4 and wait
there was a it's on YouTube uh Magnus is
playing with a Blitz game and he comes
to the game and he's got like 20 seconds
on the clock
yeah
uh at the in the game between Ali Reza
and gukash I mean talk about firing a
gun they are off and Knight A6
wow um
okay that's quite rare I would say so a
night and I see in the database there
are some top player games dinglier and
rajabo for example from last year and
what did White Shoes in that game
because I just did the result it was
zero one the black one so Dean played
Knight G2 E2 yeah C5 yeah and then white
two con A6
and that also took on C5 right and B4
and once again this was uh between ding
lyrics
and Timor got it gotcha yeah the Knight
on A6 makes a very strange impression
mirror but you don't have any moves are
you waiting for uh Magnus to join you
oh yeah yeah have some some issues with
my border bearing oh right but this
Knight A6 line that you've just uh
pointed out I do remember that game yeah
that was it's a very strange move to
begin with but yes on how it works for
black wow uh yeah it does looks
does look suspicious but Knight A6 has
been played by uh the world's best let's
see Yvonne sarage versus Fabi uh Fabi uh
again uh playing the French defense he
had a very good position against Richie
uh earlier in the tournament he plays it
again uh this time against Ivan sarich
A7 A6
Queen B6 uh most popular move A7 A6
played
by Magnus Carlson against Bobby uh from
their recent game a7a6 a283 takes Bishop
C5 Queen D2 G5
this is very very exciting there are
some top games nipponishi played this
with black two years ago against Hitler
Arjun also played this last year so it's
a new Theory and what uh what did white
play in those games F3 Knight F3 okay
inviting I suppose D4
D4
wow Bishop takes Knight takes
Knight takes and then G takes f
Okay so we've got Queen H4 on tap we've
got Knight takes E5 on tap and I'm
supposing if I go Queen takes F4 you're
going to take on E5
wow okay
Knight takes E6 if I go Queen takes E5 I
can see that you can but go both Bishop
takes D4 as well as Queen takes D4 I'm
wondering about Knight E6 though
I guess you're just going to take
open position and two Bishops good
compensation I must say wow so G5 so uh
Miro uh please tell us uh what the stats
tell us about the move G5 uh well you'd
be surprised but similarly not a bad
move and played by quite a few strong
players I can see names like Switzerland
neponishi played this position Nakamura
against bakrol played this position both
game finished in the draw
and that's about it only four games in
total it's a risky but not such a bad
move it seems
G5 right so that's that's what we have
yeah Knight F3 and F5 being two two
moves that were played
Knight F3 and F4 F5 yep yeah
let's take a look at nepo magnus's game
okay so we have kerokan my favorite
opening okay
and now we're talking and I remember
okay everybody liked at a certain moment
to play the pan off Bob vinic
attack as white with C4 Knight C3 and
then it became Bishop to G4 into in this
position became the most popular move A7
A6 quite rare very very very rare and
then the other move that Archer yusapov
amongst many other players like to play
was Bishop E6 A7 so I think G6
we still played it a few times exactly
that was one of my favorite moves as
well G7 G6
A6 Bishop G5 Bishop E6
Rook C1
the book wow yeah no the combination of
Bishop E6 and G6 yes I'm ready to accept
that but with the move A6 as well thrown
in that seems and we're overdoing it
here Magnus has only spent eight seconds
so it's prep it's prep
G6 uh what can you tell us about this uh
approach Miro once again I can tell you
your spot on not even with the analysis
but with your memory it is indeed a very
very rare line the fact is that yeah A6
and Bishop E6 which does seem to be a
bit of a weird combination it was played
relatively recently by big names mommy
Diary of granddelius eriggaisi and tongi
Haro just last year and then Rook C1 was
a novelty apparently brought by Yanni
pomishi uh not sure if again he was
planning to play it against the Magnus
it's not very often but Magnus plays
karakan nevertheless Rook C1 is a
novelty and magnus's reaction in a few
seconds G7 G6 means that he he's aware
this Rook C1 exists that's pretty much
it
wow and well I see your engine says even
the fair favoration yeah it's equal it's
equal what can you do uh well sometimes
the debate would go like don't you
really double the pawns and you know
take on D5 but usually tells a unless
you have something immediately which I
don't think you have right Bishop C4 and
then you can go Queen A5 or even
despite you've played G6 you can develop
the bishop to B4 with a check then go to
D6 or D7 with the queen black is more
than happy to play this position
gotcha
G7 Jesus yes and well it looks
provocative but it seems the best white
has is just you know more this bishop
here two Castle short and then we
pretend everything was normal
all right well very good uh let's just
jump over to the game
of uh Vichy uh non-constantine versus
Bishi this look like Queen's Gambit
accepted which it is with the Rubenstein
variation b2b3 uh a line that I like
playing as white myself B3 castles
B5 Knight D2 and the reason why this
game caught my eye is because of this
move Rook A8
A7 I remember the first time I saw this
uh
uh White in a Queen's Gambit declined it
played the move Queen B3 and Alexander
Alarcon played Rook A7 and I thought it
was the most hilarious move I'd ever
seen and
he did perfectly well
and in this case well I mean you didn't
Vichy did not want to give up the
diagonal Bishop takes F3 Queen takes F3
but rather to maintain uh the tension
and if white is interested in trading
well it's actually a remarkable instance
of The Rook moving from A8 to D7 with
Tempe with Tempe yeah it's a great idea
we do have the exchange on the board and
then uh lopulesco played Queen E2 Queen
E2
but the only problem black still has to
solve is the development of the night
right because if you play Knight D7
we're allow 96 yeah it can be unpleasant
exactly and here well I think it's just
time to evacuate uh
the d8 square so you can just play Rook
d8 and Rook D7 like you say if if I
could play a knight C6 and just
comfortably solve my development
problems that way I'm just going to be
perfectly fine I think vichys doing well
out of the opening let's jump and see
how
Yvonne handled the move G5 after G5 he
did not play Knight F3 or F5 he took on
C6 Knight to six was a novelty a novelty
okay very logical one uh but then the
question is why didn't he follow up with
capturing the pawn
it's not a pond grubber he's not an
answer he's not going to get uh
membership in the pawn scrubbers
Association uh
takes on G5 is it D4 or is it Queen C7
or Knight D7
Quincy Simon looks interesting and then
winning the E5 Pawn right because D4
would is just wrong yeah I would just be
very grateful gleefully uh but you're
saying a Queen East Queen C7 and
grabbing the e-pawn
are you
uh
uh I mean there is a king in the middle
of the board here still uh and this is
why I don't play the French yeah
good point uh Miro jump in uh here
because there was an opportunity for
Evon to grab upon and he didn't do it
why not
uh well he decided not not to as Nancy
told you right in reality I'm I dare to
claim that Fabi took a gamble going for
this line not only it's not very popular
this G5 but if you play it you really
have to know it because guess what
Knight C6 and the very next move is a
mistake he should take it he had to he
had to capture on E3 normally you know
normally you don't even stop like night
takes and it's unfamiliar with you but
you're playing a rapid game and then
well recapture is very natural but in
fact he had to take on E3 because of the
B takes Bishop C5 Knight C5 as you
correctly pointed out this was possible
and white is a pawn up like does get
some compensation with moves like Queen
C7 Rook B8 something but white is a pawn
up and not only that but sariche's move
Bishop D3 is also it's also very very
strong so now after Queen B6 they pretty
much follow the line of the computer and
apparently you cannot freely take on B2
oops that's A5 was played yeah but if
you take on B2 pretending you restore
the material for now yes but after
Castle F7 is a huge Target Rook B1 is a
threat and then Queen F2 would be double
attack on C5 and f7s that that pretty
much loses so he's dead down the pawn
with very very subtle chances of getting
real contemplates and by the way we did
see A6 A5 not exactly the brilliant
follow-up to your Pawn sacrifice uh this
no I mean it feels like Bobby is
misplayed this right I mean right now
from what I can see can choose like a
really protect this phone and just be a
pawn up H4 off you go or you can go for
for an offense with some queen of four
moves
but this wouldn't work yeah A5 and then
Queen F4 and yeah once again not a
single line that I can spot where black
is on time to do something and if you've
sacrificed the pawn and then you're
switching to protecting your weaknesses
that once again means something went
wrong indeed
um should we jump to the tournament in
litter's game exactly I wanted to do the
very same thing so from the opening uh
Duda invited the night off which was
declined no open uh Sicilian for you
said Richie Bishop B5 check 97 A4 and
for those of you who didn't want to
spend a year lifetimes studying the
night or the move Bishop B5 check in A4
was always considered a decent
alternative it doesn't promise white you
know an advantage or something of that
nature but just at least you're avoiding
this incredibly complex uh theoretical
lines B5 of course we're going to do
we're not going to allow
Queen D2 you were talking about magnus's
move uh stepping his Queen in front of
the bishop well Richie uh taking a page
out of magnus's book A5 Queen F4 and
this current position that we have on
the board is very interesting because
from the black side it's just the
Bangkok Gambit exact same setup but
White's Pawn is on D3 instead of D5
right because if that was on D5 we would
just have a bank code right and the C2
Pawn would be on A2 and then not
necessarily in a banquet camp
all right
but one on D3 tells me that black is
fine okay but this is actually funny
because we were just talking about
Alexander alekine's Rook A7 yeah now we
got Rook A2 and we get Queen D2 as well
so Richie is taking Pages out of all
kinds of world champions uh books uh
Mira what what does the engine say about
this very creative approach does he have
an advantage uh well enough to last move
Bishop C6 engine claims it to be roughly
equal but that's a very creative play
I'm still you know in admiration for
this queen D2 to a photo H4 which is a
clumsy maneuver but if you think of it
just let's go back and it's very often
that white would play a move with the
bishop I don't know where and then let's
say Let's Pretend B2 is not hanging at
all so Queen D2 and then Bishop H6 right
and if black doesn't react you're trying
to bring the queen with Queen G5 Queen
H4 later on right so despite looking
clumsy it might be that this queen D2
and getting the queen to H4 first saves
him some time right interestingly
right and once again
doesn't really matter if the engine says
it's equal what I can see is white has a
plan
while for black it's far more
problematic you do have the pressure on
the queen side yes and The Rook on A2 is
not the best piece but it stops your
play Forever
same thing yeah and white has some ideas
of going Bishop H6 Knight G5 and so on
that remarkable
the maneuver I like it I like it the tip
of the head to Richie for that by the
way I think Constantine just blundered
upon against Vichy when we left it we
had seen Bishop takes B7 Rook takes B7
Queen E2 everything's good Queen D7
something like Rook C1 Rook D1 h2h3 and
the players would battle their way
forwards he did play the move A4 and in
his mind uh White was thinking well that
way I keep your night tethered
until you see the move Rook takes B3 and
you go row row didn't I just blunder
upon and the answer is yes you did
and from here on out white will be
trying to equalize
exactly I mean and sometimes you do you
just block that out because you know
mentally you know you think your Rook is
just uh perfectly fine and protected and
that's just simply not the case where it
takes B3 and whoops I would say white
might have slight a little bit of
compensation because the Knight is still
on B8 and it's not easy to develop it
but other than that
no uh we're not happy uh again uh Queen
we haven't uh looked at
let's do it let's jump right into it and
how did they get here so this is a ninja
oh this was the Knight A6 yeah we had we
had actually left the game uh after 92
C5 Bishop takes A6 you were mentioning
that dingler in I played this position
before or previously and
I like ferocious position
he has almost all his pieces around the
black squares is that a good thing it's
like Checkers
okay and uh well
um
I've got E4 Square that's a good thing
I've got the two Bishops but I've got
the diagonal A1 h8 that's a nice
uh oops that's not a good uh my arrow
skills just left but black shirt
the double pawns can
yes I like that move very much
uh
I'm still trying to I I mean you know
it's funny what you were saying that you
you have this diagonal
but in some ways your Knights
are occupying the squares that your
queen wants to go to right so it's not
so easy for you to use that diagonal and
you know I can post up on C4 it could
even offer a trade of nights maybe
although one of the knights can can go
to B3 like Knight B3
by day five and that was why you might
want to play A5 yourself
intriguing okay cool it seems easier to
play with white
yeah I I'll I'll allow that for sure the
the dark Square Bishop let me just check
in on the game of Magnus for a moment
because this was the inclusion of G6 and
Bishop E6 and uh
fair right unless you're going to take
on F6 and take on D5 you want to have
some space 94.
Bishop E3
although
five Knight C5
that might have not been what uh Jan
expected because after takes takes is he
just going to be a preponder
take on G4 first and then on C5 well
he's not a papando right yes yeah in the
current position I think
take on G4 and then on C5 unless I'm
blundering my night but
no I don't think you are takes takes
uh
it's a little worrisome yes
but I don't have a 92 and we do have
Queen takes G5 pardon me Bishop takes G4
Queen takes G4 on the board Magnus is
being invited to grab the pawn
but if Rook D1 okay
five
yes
and for the moment it's kind of
intriguing that well Magnus is reaching
yeah 92 doesn't work because black can
take with the check exactly
it does look uh scary that you are
walking into a pin but if you don't have
the immediate moment to take advantage
then E7 E5 will be just a healthy Pawn
to the good marrow jump in on this one
uh Queen takes E5 and what is nepo going
to do and do you think he blundered
Knight takes C5
uh well this much I don't know as you
remember
um I said perhaps nepo's experiment went
a bit wrong right here when he had to
play Modest Bishop E2 and according to
computer even before this Knight C5
which is a nice tactical operation in
Black's favor Black is already better so
in fact
when he played Bishop G4 and he has to
sacrifice the pawn or gave it pawn away
it's hardly he had anything bad the
bishop G4 is the top move of the engine
wow believe it or not and you're right
black is better and why perhaps has a
choice because one thing he can do
according to machine is to go and not
anymore I mean machine was going Queen
D7 at some point but then after Queen C6
and it's a clever way in my opinion too
and pin you can win the pawn back but
then you are not very happy with your
queen on A3 and black starts jumping all
sorts of Knight to F5 Rook a to d8 and
equal material but very hard position to
play for white right so he is thinking
of the queen C5 yeah Rook D1 black just
plays not even E5 but Rook to d8
computers not sure which not sure which
work but both give black substantial
Advantage so as early as move 17
has very good chances right
as Karo Khan players uh our panel is
very uh please uh with this uh outcome
for black a Magnus looking very uh comfy
uh at this moment uh that game between
Ali Riza and good cash by the way uh
a6a5 uh that was an intriguing move he
just played Rook C7 and I liked what you
said when I was like Knight B3
um well maybe go cash wants to put
Bishop on C8 and F5 maybe that's so
that's something like this however D5 is
saying
good well spotted
nice I thought you were actually just
going to put the queen on D4 you know
because uh it was all about that
diagonal but yeah I went way and I had
instead of B3
it made F3
after Rook C7 Knight F3
okay
I guess it makes sense he wants to keep
night on the king side
after Queen D4 Maybe
well that's what it's all about is it if
we can exploit this diagonal uh land a
blow
Rook Rook C8 so no Bishop C8 that wasn't
what that was about he was just about
doubling
24 right away would be met with Rook C4
really or would it yeah that was my
question I takes D5 exactly and just
went upon yeah we've got uh Queen takes
F6 and
on tap there so Queen D4 uh Miro jump in
uh is there opportunity here for Ali
Reza uh yes there is but it's not Queen
D4 yes no and it's interesting that your
move perhaps was better The Night B3 but
perhaps was better than Knight F
dreamers but after Knight B3 there was a
strange idea for black which computer
turns to criticize
d5d4 wow because this Pawn is well it's
a burden and instead your opponed down
you're opening the bishop and yes white
is better but for this you have to take
with the queen and to follow you know a
narrow path so when you're playing the
game you might get a little bit kind of
uncertain about this and instead play
some Knight F3 so that the Rook on E1 is
protected that's what he has done now D4
makes no sense whatsoever right and
after Rook e to C8 uh Queen D4 is
something you were discussing yeah Rook
here Knight D5 and already computer is
just happy with this position white will
be a pawn up but black gets rid of all
the threats right and also the weakness
yeah that's a that's a funny thing but
sometimes losing the only weakness you
have in the position is sort of
beneficial right you don't have to care
about this dude on D5 anymore right and
yeah and with other Rook C2 or even
caption F3 black seems to get some sort
of come to play I don't know how serious
it is but computer is not unhappy as you
can see
0.4 evaluation is less than half a pawn
so that means some compensation
and the game went this route he did play
Queen D4 according to computer better
would be just to bring more stuff in
with Rook a to D1 so when we get to
capture each other's pieces The Rook
will be in play
um
so that's it we do have Queen D4 Rook
season and Rook C4 on the board and
there is no way back for white it seems
and now he has to go after this Knight
D5 and and play the end game with
some compensation for black all right
and once again for those of you joining
us late here are current standings after
two rounds in the history book this mask
we have a soul Litter with hundred
percent Jan Christoph dudo and closely
following with three points Magnus
Carlson and bishanand and with 50
Fabiano caruana which report and Ivan
sarich and just to remind everybody in
the rapid chess uh you do get two points
for a victory and that's why after only
two rounds do to S4 as he's won both of
his games in the game of Fabi Yvonne
sarich
played the move Queen F2 Rook B8 castles
Knight D7 Queen takes B6 Rook takes B6
Knight A4 whites upon up after Rook B7
Rook E1 but somehow that trade of Queens
I think for Fabi is a little bit of a
relief because the king's still in the
center yeah exactly and uh well with his
last move King E7 it's going to stay in
the center too I think why it's still
much better even in the end game is it
the H7 Pawn that's like the only thing I
know in the French H7 Point often false
right and I would love for for example
uh well just three years yeah well I
yeah I was just going to say I would
love to be able to play h4h6
and get you to trade the problem is
you're just going to play G6 on me and
uh that's all good for white so uh I've
got this week pawn on H7 and you're
about to tell me that you were going to
uh give it your attention it's the only
way black can defend It Is by night of
Fate but then I get my knight to survive
and that will be uh positionally uh
devastating uh night on f8 yeah one of
the things about the French defense that
every French defense player is aware of
if passive Bishop on C8 if it remains on
the board till the ending
goodbye you are not going to have a very
happy afternoon uh you're going to get
tortured with that uh F3 reflection well
even played H4 H4 okay it's funny I that
was the move that came to my mind but I
liked your Rook F3 I like it on both of
those moves I would suggest so black has
to play C5
all right makes sense and then it should
white probably but
C4s Maybe
not necessarily yeah
but okay I like H4 because it's just one
of those moves that it just it's so darn
challenging it just basically throws The
Gauntlet at you and says what are you
going to do if you're going to play H6
I'll play G6 and you're going to be very
unhappy and if you do nothing well you
know it's like a kind of a funny thing
but I could move my king up I could
double my Rooks
maybe one day play C3 B4 so we have C5
on the board C5 and I'm expecting B3 so
B3 is better than immediately C4 I don't
know I wouldn't make it uh
I mean in Blitzen racket rapid I'm not
sure In classical jazz and in
correspondence chess maybe I'd be very
very sure uh but yeah I would probably
play B3 but uh I couldn't understand why
C4 would also be very attractive at the
moment it's an extra Pawn for Yvonne
he's looking very good Miro uh how's
vishy doing he when we left him he was
upon up well he still is but perhaps it
was well it's just a tiny moment where
he when he really had an advantage turns
out it wasn't that simple even though I
was looking at computer evaluation I
thought yeah it's just a poem for
nothing but automatically they cut into
this position yeah the Queens attacked
if you go Queen B5 and the Queens are
getting exchanged white has enough
compensation because pieces are active
and so on right right and you would
think you want to get the queen to B7
somehow protect the a pawn and so on and
you have two routes of doing this queen
C6 or queen D7 and where she went with
screen D7 maybe preserving the C6 Square
for the Knight and all of a sudden after
Bishop E5 you do not have a comfortable
way of saving the pawn while with Queen
on C6
the bishop E5 you would play this Knight
to D7 it's an awkward move but you sort
of protecting the B8 Knight which does a
good job of protecting A6 spawn right
right and one tiny moment of losing
concentration of the bishop E5 it's
almost equal and which perhaps yeah he
was caught off guard as far as I
understand because if he wanted to play
Queen B5 he could have done it
immediately right right so now he plays
Queen B5 Queens are getting traded
Knight D4 Knight D7 and lupolesco which
is girls Bishop G3 perhaps the B Pawn is
getting lost
so that's it that's it it doesn't look
like he will have much of a chance
and I just saw that the last move was
Bishop to B4 yeah Bishop B4 attacking
the Knight now compy says well
you just have to not blunder the night
tonight F3 is sufficient Knight to B3 is
sufficient
well computer claims kind of slight Edge
in this position but you know even if
it's objectively somewhat better for why
this is not the position for black this
is not the position you win exactly a
game that we wanted to keep our eye on
as we see our tournament leader Duda
versus Richie Rapport it's a very
creative uh attacking
Maneuvers I want to say we left it after
the move Queen H4 Rook B8 we had seen
that in Rook A2 and
the first impressions are Well
everybody's happy
but white is the one that has a superior
structure to begin with he also has a
weakness that he might
chew upon and this whole concepts of
Bishop H6 and Knight G5 are attacking
ideas or patterns that we were shown
when we were youngsters uh Richard did
manage to get his Bishop on H6 but I
liked how did it responded with just
putting the bishop on h8
and that's interesting
um Gregory kaidana
once made a a very uh Stark observation
that the move Bishop h8 was the most
overrated
uh idea in chess and
what Gregory was saying is that yes
congratulations you preserve your
beautiful Bishop but on the other hand
this bishop on age six
back rank checkmates
you know and uh quite often this bishop
on H6 is far more irritating than the
bishop is on h8 let's see what happened
F4 I'm surprised both of you like
White's position maybe it's because I
played Banco with black sometimes I
think black is completely fine uh okay
well I mean the benko Gambit destroyed
let's say a generation of American
Youth the youths uh
F4 97 Miro jump in uh what does the
engine say break the tie between Nasi
and myself there's no tie anymore yes
huh no time yeah I'm on yeah
and not me right I I was I was
advocating for White's position yet but
the quality of my life just
yeah the engine just yeah you know there
is no romantism left in chess right
there is no attack the computer says no
attack you know even like you can't even
Bluff my way here as much as I was
praised in the maneuver Queen whatever
it went to get to to H4 and now
apparently what he had to do is to go
back here Queenie one which is the
admiration you know the music stopped
right Knight D1 is consistent because
you want night to eat three
and it's also bad it's consistent and
it's bad enough the C4 black will have
quite a quite a serious Advantage
already because C4 Knight C4 D5 the
positions opens up you'll get some open
files
and when you have open files you could
use some Rooks and your Rooks are stuck
on the a file a rook A1 Rook A2 are
nicely targeting the pawn which they can
never take
yeah computer tends to favor Black
heavily of the C4 and D5 I'm not sure if
it will be played but if it will
exactly in the rapid game yeah and maybe
I have to mention that the point is that
you really want to open files with
blankets exactly D5 then white of course
will be very happy to block everything
and then he is getting valuable time to
bring his Knights into attack and so on
and now computer already agrees this
one's equal and once again I well in a
practical game I would pick white here
so hence you go C4 first after Knight D1
right and white can't really afford like
not dealing with this ball and when he
takes only then you go D5
wow and if we jump to magnus's game I
think he has a huge Advantage exactly
let's do that when we left it we saw the
move Queen takes C5 challenging uh nepo
to prove his compensation nepo played
the move Queen E4 move that you had
pointed out uh uh Miro uh Queen B4
okay I think the engine was saying oh
just give back the E7 Pawn uh Queen B4
takes tags Queen takes
and we're quickly catching up with the
players but first impressions of the
minor pieces there's no competition the
bishop really is out dueling the Knight
and there goes a pawn
yeah white is just trying to draw here
exactly uh B5 Pawn is not hanging there
is a check and something about nepo's
play with the white pieces has not been
very convincing his game around one game
against Duda where he played on the
white side of escotch he
got outplayed I think here he was
surprised by magnus's A6 Bishop E6 and
G6 as we were and so were we
um yeah A5 it looks like a two result
game for sure in favor of Magnus uh
jumping to alireza and gukash
players have transposed well if you're
still up a pawn but it's a rook end in
much closer to a draw I think than it
was with the Bishops on the board
exactly
and
that
uh but it's possible I mean why it has
zero risk very pleasant end game
is it zero zero risk so if I go check
and you go rookie two let's just say
right and I take it and I go Rook here
okay Rook B7 yeah and that was my
question is this a zero risk because I
do have a H Pawn right oops excuse me
I mean yeah you've got an A Pawn I agree
but
I would see it yeah I would see it as
kind of uh all results possible there
okay
um and Nero uh what is culture uh I yeah
I was investigating once again what
happened in Jan's game against Magnus
and uh well magnus's position is better
already for quite some time right for
quite a few moves but then B3 a very
natural move you're saving the B Pawn
happens to be perhaps decisive mistake
because he was much better off either
playing Queen E2 or Rook C2 just to
preserve the stability of this Knight on
C3 so he's basically saying you want to
win a pawn you will have to exchange the
bishop on C3 first and then with major
pieces you know have a busy it'll be
much easier to transpose into some sort
of Rook end game with better chances
like once we reach this with Queen on A5
and the Knight inevitably having to move
black is completely waiting according to
machine
interestingly enough
A5 was perhaps a slight misstep really
because yeah according once again
according it's not that I'm smart but
computer knows everything so a check and
it suggests not rushing with the pawns
at all but first improving The Rook so
rookie a once again it turns out that
this Knight is unstable right that
usually you get the knight in the center
and you're very happy but no not in this
position it's very awkward so what
computer does it goes G3 and then black
trades the Queens like that
and you know you have to play F3
otherwise you're dropping the F2 pole
which is like deadly and then F5 is
possible rookie six is possible like all
the Transformations let's say Rook E6
you trade the Rooks you resign
immediately because a pawn will run and
knights are notoriously bad stopping
root pawns right right so yeah that was
and after A5 interestingly he lets white
to play G3 King G2 and maybe not fall
apart immediately but that's yeah what
do we know maybe Magnus will prove that
computer's wrong
nice uh I I like it uh it's it's hard to
criticize the move A5 because it looks
so natural to push the Palm by the way I
want to join uh draw our attention again
between Yvonne sarich and Fabi because
when we did leave it we just thought
okay it's a nice comfortable position
for Yvonne he's a pawn up but that's not
the way the cookie crumbled after hore
C5 C4 D4 Rook F4 still looks like
everything is going Yvonne's way
and we got reached this position when
suddenly and I think quite shockingly
H6 was S8 and after takes on H6 Rook
takes H6 and here it takes G5 yes
without Rook G5 why it looks fantastic
right exactly you just you you you get
this position in your mind and you think
to yourself well I'm just killing it the
night is going to come to D3 I'm a pawn
up uh you know King will everything I
mean I've got everything
takes G5 sacrificing an exchange and
suddenly uh with this very active Rook
I've got ideas of A4 would you rather be
here
uh the clock times seven minutes for
Fabi and ten for Ivan
uh-huh
I was hoping that Fabi might have a a
little bit of a Time Edge too I think
I'd rather be black I mean I
I just feel like the initiative you know
you you get so jolted when you see this
move Rook takes G5 right you've just
really thrown backwards and by the way
he did not play A4 and Bishop A6 and
capturing this Pawn on C4 he played
simple chess just wants to pick up
another Pawn exactly
Rook C3 Knight C1 is such an ugly move
and he didn't want to play it he did
play King E2 so inviting Rook takes B3
and Miro jump in on this one because I'm
thinking the move Rook takes G5 really
turned the tables yeah you're right you
are yasa and if not for Rook G5 you're
absolutely right in this position right
of the G5 if not for Rook G5 you might
as well resign exactly okay I will not
go back because I have to say that Cyrus
was completely winning at some point
right close to being completely winning
but the current position is super
interesting because after King E2 yeah
as unclimatic as it is you have to go
Rook C2 according to computer and repeat
really and yeah and the problem is I
mean the funds starts a bit later like
if you take on B3 which is what you want
to do not have kind of powerful enough
threats you do have some threads but
they are not enough so white go through
F1 and then if your inventive you go
King E8 so now if Rook takes F7 you'll
take on D3 right and it works for you
and then white has some G6 Pawn takes
Rook H4 and still it's it's closer to a
draw but you might regret not taking a
draw you know well if Rook Rooks
penetrate like Rook h8 Rook H7 so it's a
little bit sad and I believe Fabi will
never take it and by the way he played
Bishop G2 so he is not he's not playing
for a draw after which according to
computer well it once again shifts in
White's favor but the game goes on and
anything can anything can happen instead
of the mirror instead of the move Rook
to C3 which I I again it looks very very
attractive if A4 yeah but A4 turns out
B4 is very strong because if white ever
gets to take the default Pawn he solves
a lot of his issues right I wanted
Bishop Aces yeah I was I was so
myopically focused on Bishop A6 I forgot
that you could play B5 as well after
Bishop G2 interestingly the computer
still recommends B4
yeah this is how it claims that white is
white is still better and the line would
be something like a b a b let's just get
to the end of the line and see how
realistic White's Chance is going to be
so it captures on C5 Knight C5 right and
yeah
even this one I would not be 100 sure
that black is safe
it looks very close to BF Fortress but
not the Fortress yet exactly not a
fortress yet
I got some updates that demand is
winning at
well well he was better yeah we thought
he was seriously better but uh really
close to equal in the end game but now
looks like
um yeah we left it we left it at Bishop
B4 with ideas of Bishop to C3 and Rook
to D1 we want to take this Pawn on B5
obviously B4 Rook
page three
and it's
for now
just defending the pawn well that's what
we heard from
and Knight to C2 and give me the pawn
I'm trying to induce you to play the
move B3
yeah B3 just go back 94. exactly exactly
can I try Rook C6 here
and if I okay
oh oh I'm not mated
yes you're not made it but the two
Knights versus The Rook with uh with all
the pawns on one side of the board that
should be winning for the knights
although it's not you know a layout
layup that uh
and uh marrow over to you how is our
tournament leader doing uh wow very
impressive he might be you know he might
be 100 after today's day uh so C4 that
moved that I was suggesting with the
help of my little silicon friend was not
played instead he went with Rook A7 and
another stage of maneuvering Rook a to
B7 so doubles on the B file and then
basically what white did he has sorry
it's a bishop G5 First bishop G7
and here I wonder if white would have
gone Bishop H6 would black accept the
draw we never know because Richie was
very aggressive and he has done do this
job pretty much he went F5 to open the
position up
and once again it turns out it's uh well
you didn't want to open the position
Rook B4 is very strong kind of
distracting all the coordination
possible Queen g395 and you can feel
that black pieces start to jump and the
center is open and then you have Knight
on D1 and both Rook start both Rook
stuck on the A4 yeah Bishop E8 and you
have to make it ugly and uglier moves
just to keep your position together yeah
like if you have to play Bishop E2 once
again it's not the reason you've played
the five of your moves earlier exactly
yeah and now something like rookie 8
bringing the Rook over the E file and
yeah it looks critical for for white
computer is very harsh it's plus almost
plus two for black
wow wow
plus two wouldn't have imagined that but
I think the fun begins now since they
are both approaching the blitz time
control five minutes on the clock
uh for for both of them for both sides
yes yeah
it's a strange position because because
both sides need to be so accurate and
it's not easy with five minutes on the
clock no it's not and those five minutes
boy I tell you when you when you're down
to your last five minutes you feel like
you're under constant pressure by the
way it moves C uh to C3 uh so dude I
didn't play rookie eight as Miro
suggested he played Queen D7 yeah
and I'm assuming the Rook is just going
to drop back well then white has D4 and
9th dropped on E5 was Queen D7 a blunder
because nine has nowhere to go
let Richard immediately
I did see that at all
uh uh let's check with Mira yeah yeah it
is it is it was it wasn't blunder and
well luckily for him he has some time to
stop to realize that the Knight is about
to get trapped because according to the
machine black Still Remains as kind of
retains a slight Advantage by going Rook
G4 in the exchange But first you have to
understand Amino rather Comfort yourself
with the idea yes I messed up a little
bit which is very hard during the rapid
game right I didn't find this Rook G4
and then after Bishop takes Knight takes
white pieces are still so awkward that
black is slightly better but not nearly
as much as he used to be so Miro I'm
confused why isn't D4 still trapping the
Knight here uh why is D4 not trapping
the Knight here because Queen takes F5
and Bishop on G5 is hanging yeah so
that's why and computer is so relaxed
that after sorry over here after you
capture on G6 for instance it takes with
the pawn it's it's really sure that this
Knight is not getting trapped
you know
since I'm stealing the show let me
inform you that Madness blew all of his
Advantage away
really yes look I mean A5 A4 remember we
were talking this one and then there was
I think there was one tiny moment after
Rook A6 Queen B4 according to machine
would still keep the advantage and
creepy 3 he has well I'm speculating of
course but apparently he has blonded
this funny looking move Knight to C5 and
then if you trade you inevitably lose
the a pawn right so he went with Queen
to B4 and now you probably don't want to
take because the Knight is very awkward
right and rookie a just wins according
to machine once again but nepo played it
very very precise from now on so Queen
D5 he uses the you know the activity of
the pieces right well and black steel
cannot establish the coordination A3
Pawn seemingly survives Knight B3 Queen
C3 Queen D6
and the pawn is gone check here Bishop
B2 Pawn is still here but you know few
more moves may not be started I'd be
optimistic about White's chances I mean
the queen clearly got stuck right he did
play Queen before Queen B4 is one one of
the moves yeah and then
in fact perhaps the simplest move
because you can't really extract all the
stuff from the corner if you go Queen A2
it just takes on B2 Queen takes Queen
takes Pawn takes and Rook B6 only but
sufficient for B6 right and I must say
this almost never happens but nepo's in
time trouble nepo has far less time than
Magnus and that's why that's why he
plays a good game he just has to think
okay he has one minute against eight
minutes
by the way Duda did not play the move
Rook G4 against uh Richie he dropped his
Rook back Rook back to B6 and Richie
said okay but wait a minute what about
D3 D4 uh trapping the Knight you see
epic clearance for a pawn
um what's the best way to give up that
piece well exactly there is no best way
I'm afraid if I take
take
Knight G4 right for night night
this one's protected so yeah one is
protected
a slightly awkward placement of pieces
for white but an extra piece it's
temporary right because Queen takes you
do have Bishop F3
oh yeah
Bishop F3
um yeah I mean Duda did not find the
move Rook G4 and he's currently looking
at a lost piece and uh Vichy
really well in The Rook ending yeah he's
a pawn upon up and he got his other
opponent H4 wow which is a brilliant
um
achievement achievement yes exactly and
King to uh
yeah
and Constantine is down to 28 seconds to
be eight minutes yes so Vichy in cruise
control how is Fabby doing well fabby's
trying to set up a fortress which he may
or may not achieve it might be a very
long game yeah and uh definitely a two
result game for Yvonne as he enjoys uh
being in exchange I should mention how
Yvonne is an underdog in this tournament
he's doing great two draws one of them
against Magnus Carlson where he we think
he had a brilliant geometry there yeah
exactly I could have won the game easily
and now against Fabi playing for two
results exactly
by the way uh as you started the show
there Mira one of the things you were
showing is that that we have five-time
world champion Magnus Carlsen five-time
world champion Vision on five-time
Romanian Champion Constantine
two-time Champion
I mean we were on the fives you know
three fives uh or we were doing very
very well five times five times
and then a five-time uh
Romanian Champions are there and then
only two go away
from Yvonne sarage but Mira also
mentioned that sarich has a win in a
classical game against Magnus which a
very few people in the world do that is
for sure okay
um
exactly uh versus
we thought so uh and we were kind of
saying that it's still oh he did not
play by the way yeah he didn't play Rook
C2 he went Rook H5 right away
and okay well now white is definitely
doing well
but at the same time we don't have
enough Pawns
to push yeah we'd like more right uh
because I think Rook D7 will just what
happens taken Rook D6
uh what what are you planning taken Rook
D6 and then I've got a check right
everything goes up definitely not down
guys to G6 wow by the way we do have a
draw in the game between uh nepo and
Magnuson nepo's like what am I doing
with the white pieces
um why are you happy about your King on
G6 here
after for example F4
oh I just thought how does white improve
oh
and then you can't cross the defile
or if I just stay Rook T1 Rook D6
right interesting so even though I've
got this this past Pawn on D7
yeah and take A7 and try to win sure
different end game okay but that's
that's uh not so clear uh at all uh
uh let's jump to the game of Richie for
a second because uh we're taking down
the tournament leader exactly when we
left it we were curious to see what Duda
was going to do just to save his Knight
on D4 on on E5 after the move d4 Rook to
B3
Queen takes
so white is the one
winning material
but Bishop takes E5 and
I think you can even take Rook takes E4
now I was about to say we could even
grab this guy right we don't have to we
can just play Bishop F4 but rookie four
looks nice rookie four well anything
that will
bring about change texture we have three
pieces for two for a rook and two ponds
it should be more than enough yeah three
pieces will easily dominate so Rook
takes E4 we think is winning
F2 whoa
so I'm still I'm stuck materials
just uh for one Pawn right yes
peace for one Pawn and his training in
the bishop only four and also maybe
bishop C4
and dude I just made a move with one
second one second on his clock oh my
gosh
I mean they must go to some training
school where they learn to press the
clock with a second Bishop C4 Rook takes
I just love the way dude I just snapped
off the move rooked you know his Queen's
hanging his Rook is hanging and Rook
takes B2 so whack through the math
Bishop is six yes four takes F2 roof
takes F2 Take Back The Rook
then take on A4 how many pieces are
hanging oh take on A4 or I thought you
were going to take on E6 I want to take
a bigger piece and this she won against
Constantine
uh sorry you wanted to do what
184 take on A4
and I'll take on F7 King G7
King G7 because you can't take Knight A4
no
but you're already still at this I'm
still affect these but uh for the moment
no it's just it should be it should be
aware so how do we defend Bishop the
first Rank and the night
they should I take oh you take with the
check
yes just in time Moro Cafe here are you
pinned I'll take the Knight oh sorry God
my knight will take your Bishop sorry
it's getting it's getting early here
uh Rook takes B2 let me just refresh my
board uh excuse me everybody I'll be
right back here Rook takes B2 jump in
mirror is there a clear he did take on
easy well there is a clear way but it
does involve some not so natural move
yeah Rook F2 is a must yes enough
position A4 you have to capture on F7
with the Rogue
Bishop F6 is the way to go yeah is the
way to go nice that's that's far simpler
Rook takes F 7 is threatening uh a
discover check
and here's the Moment of Truth not
Bishop F7 which is
7 the only way to well Bishop F7 does
lead to White's Advantage but Rook F7 is
much much stronger and of course Richard
finds it very impressive
and by the way a draw did occur between
uh Ali Reza and gu cash Rook takes F7
nice move
uh and now we're expecting after King h8
which was played Bishop F6 check now
Bishop F6 but Knight E2 seemingly works
as well
92 it would involve some awkward move
like Knight G1 but still at the end you
still have Bishop F6 it's official D4
yeah you also have fruit Cafe to check
King juicer oh checkmate
that's better yeah
that's better
I think Duda again made a move with one
second because he has 11 seconds right
now wow
wow
and reach it down to 30 seconds I think
I saw that annotations one that
annotation one time in my local magazine
Northwest chess uh you know Rook f8
check and Rook G8 Checkmate was better
still winning according to computer but
not the most precise not as clean
oh look he provoked Duda to move the
road
because now the best movie is Rook V8
which I did
he did make and now we do have Knight E2
and Knight G1 as you were pointing out
yeah I think he has to move that night
exactly how much time for a Richie by
the way uh but they both have about 15
seconds okay
but it's only one Pawn it's only one
Pawn for the night that's
it's not enough but there is still room
to blunder like say black girls Bishop
C6 you're trying to make a lift for the
king and you really cannot because even
if the H Pony moved the G Pawn the king
is still vulnerable in the first rank
right so Knight G1 G1 by the way love
that
so when you have an extra piece you can
afford to put one on G1 exactly I was
about to say if it was my turn I'd
really like to put the bishop on D5 and
just as you know you're saying you make
love for the King which is why uh Duda
is trying to make uh life as difficult
for Richie as possible Bishop C6
whoa he took me back
Rich he wanted to play H4 he wasn't he
hesitated thought about H3 and said
never mind H4 is fine
Bishop to Deep
so just night of what can the night come
out or no not yet
well if worse ever comes to worse right
can we just play Rook FH yeah but we
don't want to we don't want to I
understand
Rook to C7
so what it does have an issue how do we
bring the king and night out
true and we just saw the move D5 let's
not forget their playing with just 10
seconds on the clock by the way no that
is a dirty dirty move right D5
protecting the bishop but
uncovering a uh attacking on The Rook
Rook uh to d7b this Pawn is just
marching down it is annoying uh the
desirable Knight F3 always Bishop C4
probably Bishop D5 okay okay yeah if we
can finally finally yeah breathe now
well of course dude is not interested in
making
uh like but on the next move now we can
finally
develop stuff on the king side
Bishop F6 I think will walk into Rook F7
yes it did
and now Bishop D5
and now you're saying
you want to play that F3 but I still
can't yeah how frustrating
15 seconds
can I maybe just play G3 give up one
pawn and bring the pieces out
there you go guess what
from your lips to his ears and there's a
bishop G7 check too by the way that
might not be a pawn that you want to uh
grab protocol just D3 D3 Knight F3
finally
yeah I mean it's like such a relief to
get that night and there you have it D3
Knight F3
and right now Vichy is our soul leader
at the moment because he has plus two
and these two are
fighting to catch or well if Dura wins
them he will surpass he will surpass but
that's very unlikely right
so Richie can catch Anand exactly I
think
and by the way we think that Fabby is
going to which is playing for the second
place
first one against
exactly
clock is becoming a an issue right
um do this after 30 seconds
Richard 25.
and uh
it turned out to be a draw
as Bobby managed to hold uh what we
thought was going to be a very difficult
ending was a brilliant idea it really
was uh Rook B8 because Rook f8 checked
and mate was on the board as a threat
King F3 and finally it really does feel
like Richie is now taking the game uh
under control now we can see that he
actually has an extra piece yes and an
active and active King
yes
Bishop C8
[Music]
Knight C4
also it's very attractive to just
get rid of this if we can get this
bishop off this diagonal we've got
Bishop G7 and a Checkmate coming up
so Bishop has to go to A1
is it three yeah A1 I was wondering if I
could chase you down you know with that
uh Rook A7 but Bishop C3 oh maybe we can
check him out with a knight now 96
I think it's coming oh yes I think
you're right
G4 nice move
Bishop C8 and then Knight D6 right yep
Richard uh bounced back quickly after
his last round loss
nine nine seconds for today
but he knows it's over
reluctantly played I must say
it's their final touches how would you
play this
safe or no I know 96 uh sure feels like
it's one of those moves you kind of feel
in your bones you know it's kind of like
an automatic
52 you can just take Bishop D2 exactly
yeah exactly
resignation very short yeah that one
really hurts Bishop takes D2 your Rook
is hanging the bishop is hanging
and thank you
Bravo Richie
whoa as he knocks off our tournament
leader at Legend the tiger of Madras is
still roaring at the Miro when you came
on the show you were telling us how you
have been retiring yeah once again and
again and again you try to retire yeah
story yes I was I think it was Qatar or
Saudi Arabia that one of the rapid and
Blitz World Championships yes and at the
beginning of the tournament I've
mentioned something yeah we cannot
expect not on air but you know in
private that well it's hard to expect
something from Wishy because yeah he
lost the Magnus perhaps he's more of a
semi-retired and he wins the tournament
of course
world champion yes World rapid champion
and uh let's go to Zagreb as Christian
is with Magnus
Magnus saw a slower start in Poland a
much quicker one uh here in Zagreb you
mentioned that you love playing here in
Zagreb sum it up uh the day for us yeah
it was a very interesting day three
fighting games
um on another day I could perhaps have
eked out so a win or even two more but
uh I'm I'm fairly further satisfied and
you started off with a pretty amazing
hot Victory against gokish tell us a bit
about gokish how do you see him as a
player after this point he's such a
young phenom
uh you know uh he's so young but I think
uh his his play especially in faster
time controls it's going to go up and
down so right now he's he's struggling
um but I'm sure he'll strike back
quickly as I think his General
understanding of the game is very good
let's talk about the game tell us where
you felt uh you created enough balance
to yeah it's uh it's it's a line that's
been fairly topical for a few years
um and um yeah I was not so sure about
the sniping three move
um it's very concrete
um which is the way he often often plays
but
[Music]
um
I I don't think it was was very good so
this was clearly the the plan to go for
I don't know yeah because all these in
all these lines I sort of need to take
away the C I Square so I it's you you
often start in this these positions like
which moves I want to play yeah I want
to play B6 and then let's see if we can
make it worth tactically I I felt more
on General grounds than anything else
that with his Knight on B3 I should
always be doing well here
um
I was not in prep here
uh I even had some crazy ideas like
taking here oh sorry not Bishop
um
takes E7 and they're going H3 that's why
he's attacking the exchange
foreign
was pretty
awesome
um
but yeah here I played too quickly
unfortunately uh F5 was really really
weak
um for instance I could have gone for
Rook 88 and I just rejected the move on
General grounds because I'm just forcing
The Rook where he wants to go but then
just left
I think I'm doing oh computer even says
I can go like there's nothing close to
an attack so that was a pretty serious
misjudgment actually after Bishop G5 I
oh uh I realized what I what I'd done so
I I started to
spend a lot of time but I didn't really
come up with anything
um for instance if I go like Rook C8 now
I think you can go probably Bishop F4
uh if I take Rook E3 is coming and he
has got a pretty good
set up there so I didn't feel
comfortable so I decided to play for
activity and here he made a really
really important decision
um he absolutely had to go Rook F1 which
is just also what I've been uh what I've
been focusing on this Rook C8 and it
felt to me that
um I was not risking much
um but also
he's very much in the game
but from a practical perspective you
still felt like yeah it still felt like
I was okay but probably not really
better a while after the movie made I
don't know what he missed because he
played it very fairly quickly and my
first thought this
doesn't this just lose to H6 and after
you know after thinking for a bit that
was my second and third thought as well
and now his Bishop
should be forced away
um
so I have this Pawn chain Rook C7 is
always meant by Rook CA so it's from
here on I mean I took my time but it was
it was more of a mopping
off yesterday you also played an
important event uh the all-encompassing
title Tuesday you finished on 11 out of
11. how did that uh give you enough
confidence for today yeah for the rest
of the tournament yeah it felt really
good uh usually when I play those
tournaments I start off okay and then I
I tilt a bit at the end and I end up
with a pretty bad feeling and to be
honest like
screening 11 out of 11 made me so
excited that it was hard to sleep
afterwards so I'm like I had I didn't
really get enough sleep for today but
still uh yeah I was was a fun it was a
fun feeling definitely 11 out of 11 can
keep you buzzing congratulations Magnus
we'll see you tomorrow thank you
thank you Christian 11 11 11 out of 11
in the title Tuesday Blitz tournament is
a frightening thought to anybody who's
playing and uh and uh Zagreb uh pretty
scary uh let's take a look at the
standings after our first day of Rapids
right after three rounds we have a soul
leader vision and who would have
expected right
[Laughter]
then with plus two Magnus Carlsen young
Christoph Duda and Richie Rapport right
uh 50 Fabiano caruana and even sarich
and ferozan cash and lupuleska will try
to bounce back tomorrow exactly
especially
leads our tournament Miro uh as you say
at the start of the show uh you try to
write vishy up but he keeps bouncing
back when you least expect him to
uh right that that's that's exactly what
happens and and if you listen to his
interviews he's lost lasted few years
he's very modest yeah I'm enjoying the
game I'm trying to be the ambassador try
to play against him exactly
and uh speaking of vishi let's go back
to Zagreb and Christian as the man of
the hour is with Christian
thanks yasury yes we are indeed with the
man of the already five-time world
champion vishwanathan Vichy last year in
Poland you started three out of three in
fact in the first day of Rapids day two
and a half a pretty decent start tell us
about uh your day
it's a very nice start
um
with alireza
he at some point I was losing control
because I went to Bishop D4
and I think that's a mistake I had
simply missed uh perhaps we can get that
through that game going on
Bishop to D4 yeah somewhere on that
so he
I don't know what implemented this move
yes
yeah he commented Knight G4 and of
course I could play E5 and maybe it is
unpleasant for him after Bishop F4
let's play E5 and it should be
but I got gradient I thought if I spent
throw Bishop D4 in and after E3 Bishop
takes E3 and then E5 is very strong but
then that's very nice yeah
but um
yes sorry yeah I was wondering where the
F Pawn was but yeah
so uh key
but he found he played Knight C4 and
then I realized there was a hole in my
calculation because after E5 that is
simply E3
and now I kind of wondered about e takes
F4
uh but it I I felt in the end it might
it's more likely to be wrong than right
yeah so is it because of the structure
no it's just that I'm losing this Pawn I
have a little potential on the king side
let's say fg3 has G3 and then maybe the
queen transfer to H5 but I couldn't
really believe that this would work so
then I decided to bail out with Bishop
takes B2
yes
and I think he could take with the
g-pawn
I thought the e-born was fine as well
but the J gives them more potential when
something is taken like already I can't
play Queen D5 because of H3 and Rook
takes C5
this trick this trick is happening quite
often in the game
so um
what also I didn't realize is I can't
play Knight gf6 here because of root
takes C5 so I'm not I was kind of just
paralyzed there so then I came up with
the Rook fc8
and then realized I have not solved H3
Knight F6 Rook takes C5 at all yeah so I
just Blended right back into that
so yeah well you can see it was a
chaotic game but then at some point he
just blundered Queen D4
but I think it's pretty close to
equality I would say yeah so in the end
he wasn't risking very much but
um
so this one finished in yeah the only
draw uh in today's rounds for you but
then obviously it's so important to
finish on high note and you did that in
a very difficult game because it's so
easy to liquidate everything and just
make a draw in this type of positions
yet with limited material you managed to
convert again I mean he went through
care fundamental text V3 and he was a
little bit shocked yes uh I think it
just slipped his mind so putting on here
with the corner I did I didn't even
think it was really winning yeah I
thought the edge must be very small so
okay one I missed wish me five I mean
queen before Bishop A3 Queen B7 looked
weak to me I couldn't really believe
that apron's gonna go anywhere yeah but
you know as long as it's alive it's
bothering him but we went for this and
then I'm just doing Miracles not lose
the a pawn so I what did I come up with
I went came up with Queen B5 that's very
nice take take
it
there might be a there might well be a
good move like Queen C4 rocking F1 which
might be better than what he did like
King F1 is a great move to throw in
first of all it leaves me with an a pawn
a rather weak upon and
is improving but not yet right not yet
not yet but uh I'm threatening Bishop
takes B8 and Rook takes A6 so uh
yeah but the problem this position is
enough there isn't a draw but you know
when you're playing with white you need
to nail it and that's that's where the
hope for me came
so I and one thing I've noticed you were
also putting a lot of pressure on your
opponent's uh clock you're playing very
very fast
I
be hard to find emotion which doesn't
lose upon so I found Bishop B4
before yes
um
the one I have to take yes he takes and
then I go B4 and this pawn it looks like
it should fall but again with my Knights
I'm going to do some Bishop d694 is a
nice trick but he starts with The Rook
yes and then I have to stop Knight C6 I
briefly considered E5 but sorry so Rook
C8
so Bishop D6 I don't know excuse me I'm
not here I'm the first I have to play uh
Rook uh A8 or C8 not here sorry first I
have player okay
but he could have played ah so he wanted
to play something
see and I'm still threatening uh the
thing Checkmate yeah he doesn't have
time he doesn't have time
so so what if he goes F3 here
I would
plan my name now you have rookie before
Knight C5 I know here actually I
considered Rook C two
Rook C1 check
yeah and again by Miracle I'm not losing
that pawn
but I would have had to check everything
at the board because you could easily
blunder into a background thing yeah in
fact I've just blundered into it okay C5
Knight C2 yes it's not even like yeah
so the margin of error is oh no I have
Rook D5 here but that pawns really not
gonna it's not long for this world so
um
so he played the route to B2
and and 95 is a good trick here because
if he goes Rook C2 I simply call Knight
C3
and there is no way he can and then if
the Knight comes to D3 and so on I'm
really connecting with you guys together
nicely yeah
so he took this anyway and now he just
has a bad choice he can play 85 and D6
and you know with my a pawn there's some
hope but I would say decent winning
chances for black yeah yeah yeah and
what he did
went down very fast
in fact here I realized that
I after G4 I really ought to have known
this
fj3 is just winning
okay King James
and then take a king for all the long
walks here their hitch Pawn might drop
and so on I think I think they should be
winning but what I did was fine as well
I mean I
someone keeping the hedge fund also is
very tempting yeah
his problem was he has gone G5
if he didn't I would play F6 and King G6
but now that he's gone there I'll take
on H3 and what happened to the game
you're just coming off a very intense
tournament as well the global chess
league if it was like all of the players
that are warmed up in this event do the
yourself Magnus who are performing well
or coming from that tournament do you
feel playing more before uh helped you
as well for me it made a huge difference
because I got a chance to play chess
after a fairly long break so for me the
global chess League was very useful to
remember how to play chess and
well I wouldn't draw too many
conclusions from one day that's uh I
mean I hope this continues but let's see
tell me about the gukesh you've been
mentoring this uh young Prodigy for
quite a long time we've seen you give
him a lot of advice during events as
well tell us a bit about him
so in 2020 when I started my
Academy
there were these four young Grandmasters
very very young and they were all at the
age of 14 15 thereabouts
and
I mean I expected them to make huge
leaps anyway but particularly
um
gokesh has done very very well Prague
also had a sensational year I think it
wasn't fully reflected because he was
playing more rapid and Blitz than
classical so his classical rating wasn't
budging but now he's making up for that
but gukesh is very very impressive he's
just one of the he's now the top 15 or
something and that's fantastic for him
and he had a very incredible result in
Norway so
um
yeah I'm very happy that he's doing well
Wishy congratulations once again on a
great start to this tournament and we'll
see you tomorrow thank you
thank you Christian uh very very nice
fishy congratulations on day one and our
schedule uh Nasi we'll be back tomorrow
for day two rapid rounds four to six
right and we have four more days of
exciting chess two more days of rapid
and two days of Blitz coming up and each
day of the Rapids uh will be two points
for each game and in the blitz just the
traditional one point uh scoring system
as vishianan takes a clear lead of five
out of six not bad and here are our
predictions
I was doing really well for two rounds
yes
Anastasia joined and nobody picked Vichy
I think Mira really wanted to uh well
yeah but yeah I ended up with Fabi which
isn't bad right Bobby's just behind you
guys right and again to all of those who
joining us a little late we we
handicapped ourselves we're not picking
Magnus Magnus being a wild card in the
tournament and the highest rated player
wouldn't be uh that fair
and uh let's just jump to zagref for
some final thoughts of uh day one over
to you Anastasia and Christian
well I have to say my pick is uh not
warmed up yet firusha has been having
quite some difficult games especially in
uh my pet opening as well the groomfield
yeah unfortunately he just didn't know
the opening very well and he got
punished by dudas swiftly in that one
still plenty of games to recover but I
have to say I'm impressed with the way
Vichy Anand is conducting himself just
an incredible player he is and you can
see how the class is shining through in
this event Anastasia what caught your
eye yeah of course if I'm talking about
my big young sister dude I was really
disappointed with the last game I think
he was really doing well and then
something happened and Richie won at the
end and I think he was really unhappy at
the end that it turned this way but
otherwise the day was actually great and
lots of people came to the plane Hall
and many kids by the way you were today
on the seat Center also spotted you
European Union just European Union
president as well you know watching the
games as well as former world champion
Gary kasparo who was coming from time to
time to the plane Hall to to follow the
games you know not online but live and
it was really nice to see him so excited
about the games and everything of course
lots of Chess fans around and lots of
wives and it was interesting also how
the crowd was moving depending on where
Ivan sarich was playing or Magnus
Carlson you know sometimes they were on
the left and then you could suddenly see
everybody was concentrated in the middle
and I mean it was it was fun day and
really there was speaking about those
two players that game between each other
Magnus and Ivan sarich and at some point
when they finished the crowd started
applauding exactly what's your price
there was still one game left the last
ball that moment that was interesting
moment you said I was there at this this
moment and actually started to hear to
hear this clouds and then you know Magda
started to analyze the game with the one
and they were probably quite loud and
director made some warning and then they
realized that Fabi is still playing and
they were like shocked and this is this
kind of moment when you realize that
there are some other people playing in
this Hall I think everybody had had it
before and so you can see actually all
those videos in our social media
accounts so please follow my Instagram
account of granchester Twitter and
Facebook and you will see a lot of
things there which were happening during
the day great energy great games from
Zagreb back to you guys in the studio
and we'll see you tomorrow with day two
thank you Anastasia and thank you
Christian reminded me forcefully of my
the tournaments in Yugoslavia where the
crowds were so knowledgeable when the
grand old man of Yugoslav chess verisar
gligerich with sacrifice in exchange the
crowds would be shouting Bravo gliger
I know it was just so so so good uh Miro
uh join us for the final thoughts of
this first day of rapid and Bliss no
like wrapping first day up I have to say
today we had everything which advocates
for the rapid chess for Rapid time
control right I would argue because well
quality games like deep preparation but
also this drama-filled you know finale
is when you have like 10 seconds or
sometimes two seconds each right and
then they're blitzing on increment and
devaliation goes up and down and yeah so
that's I'm really excited for today and
let's uh let's see what happens next
absolutely thank you very very exciting
round thank you all for joining us we
hope you join us tomorrow the same time
same channel uh really wonderful have a
pleasure for joining us and see you
tomorrow bye bye everyone
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited